est encore populaire et donc évidemment
sa façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon et disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et tenus à bonne
distance toujours et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 1er juillet 2020 nous n'avons
pas le contrôle total actuellement le
docteur anthony fauci alerte sur la
situation de la pandémie de covile aux
états unis le directeur de l'institut
américain des maladies infectieuses
déplore le tout ou rien pratiqué par
nombre d'américains soit complètement
conflits nés soit sans aucune
distanciation ni masque 4e et arizona
texas et floride représente aujourd'hui
est la moitié des nouveaux cas aux etats
unis toujours c'est au tour de facebook
de commencer à durcir le ton le géant du
web annonce de nouvelles raids contre
les propos racistes diffusé sur le
réseau social une décision sous la
pression prise après le boycott il est
dit de 400 grandes marques sur sa
plateforme qui ont rejoint le mouvement
hashtag stop stop stop it
le controversé plan de paix américain
pour le proche orient au centre de
toutes les attentions le gouvernement
israélien devrait se prononcer à partir
d'aujourd'hui sur la mise en oeuvre de
ce projet il prévoit notamment
l'annexion par israël de plusieurs zones
de la cisjordanie
mais l'élection qu'ils pourraient
embraser le proche orient
[Musique]
paris se retire d'une opération de
l'otan en méditerranée cette décision
fait suite à un incident naval survenu
le 10 juin au large de la libye entre
une vraie grotte cris frégate française
et une frégate turque
le ministère français des armées indique
que la france exigerait désormais à des
réponses de l'otan concernant ces
frictions avec la turquie
à hong kong des premières arrestations
après l'adoption hier de la nouvelle loi
sur la sécurité nationale
sept personnes ont été interpellées au
total ce sont 480 personnes qui ont été
arrêtées notamment pour avoir participé
à des rassemblements non autorisés ils
étaient des milliers de manifestants à
défier des autorités en ce jour
d'anniversaire de la rétrocession de la
ville à la chine
[Musique]
de quarante mille nouveaux cas par jour
les états unis pourrait passer à 100
milles si on ne renverse pas à la
tendance
une prévision pessimiste signé anthony
fauci l'un des médecins les plus
écoutées outre atlantique
face à la résurgence de l'épidémie dans
le pays plusieurs états ont décidé de
reconfirmer pour éviter le pire
le racing signé rania berrada l' alerte
donnée par quatre médecins la tête des
grands organismes de santé américain
suffira-t-elle à inverser la tendance
face à la résurgence de l'épidémie dans
plusieurs états ils ont appelé ce mardi
les américains et en particulier les
jeunes à se couvrir le visage et à
éviter le plus possible les foules
parmi ces hauts responsables antony
fortier qui dirige l'institut des
maladies infectieuses qui dépend du
ministère de la santé
ce mardi face aux sénateurs il a livré
une prédiction sinistre prosterne
michael d nous avons actuellement plus
de 40 mille nouveaux cas par jour
je ne serais pas surpris si nous
atteignons cent mille par jour si on ne
remercie pas la tendance je suis donc
très inquiet face à cette situation
sanitaire désastreuse
un sénateur républicain enjoint le
président des états unis a lui-même
porté un masque pour montrer l'exemple
malheureusement cette façon très simple
de sauver des vies est devenue un débat
politique
si vous êtes pour preuve il ne portait
pas de masque et si vous êtes contre
trump vous emporté 1-2 c'est pour cela
que je suggère au président de porter un
masque à certaines occasions même si
cela ne lui semble pas nécessaire aucun
commentaire de donald trump qui continue
de tenir la chine pour responsables de
la propagation de l'épidémie aux états
unis quand je regarde la pandémie
répandre son horrible visage à travers
le monde y compris les dégâts qui ont
été faits aux états unis je deviens de
plus en plus en colère contre la chine
les gens peuvent le voir et je peux le
sentir dès son côté joe biden a annoncé
qu'il ne tiendrait pas deux meetings
avant l'élection présidentielle de
novembre
c'est ce dimanche d'un vieux jours
il s'agit de la campagne la plus étrange
de l'histoire moderne me semble-t-il
je vais suivre les consignes du docteur
pas juste pour moi mais pour le pays
mais cela veut dire que je ne vais pas
organisé de motifs face à la résurgence
de l'épidémie
de plus en plus de villes et d'état ont
suspendu leur déconfinement certains en
laissant fermer les bars et les cinémas
d'autres en interdisant l'accès aux
plages ne pas porter de masque à miami
beach
y compris dans la rue coûte désormais 50
$ aux contrevenants dans le sud de la
floride
tous les feux d'artifice du 4 juillet
jour de fête nationale ont été annulés
pour en parler nous sommes économisées
bouton avocat au barreau de washington
vont former des piétons merci d'être
avec nous alors des propos du dr fauci
pas vraiment rassurant l'épidémie qui
n'est pas contrôlée des chiffres qui
pourraient encore augmenter davantage
quel est l'état d'esprit des américains
est ce qu'il ya une forme de panique aux
états unis dont les endroits les plus
touchés
ça commence effectivement on a une
reprise de la pandémie par le sud et par
le l'ouest c'est-à-dire d etat qu des
zones qui jusqu'à présent n'avaient pas
été touchés par le virus
et qui donc aujourd'hui d'une certaine
manière rattrape le reste du pays
en revanche dans le nord-est par exemple
on a une on a une baisse sensible du
nombre de 2,2 de contamination ce qui
fait que la réaction des gouverneurs qui
sont en première ligne dans chacun des
états pour lutter contre la pandémie
pour prendre les mesures contre la
pandémie est en fait assez disparate
c'est à dire que dans les états du sud
très touchés comme en floride au texas
en arizona en particulier on a
recommencé art confiner les restaurants
sont fermés les bars ont fermé un
certain nombre de lieux clos sont fermés
alors que dans d'autres zones on
continue à des confits des comme par
exemple autour de washington
donc tout dépend comme c'est un pays
fédéral bien entendu tout dépend un
petit peu de la gravité de la pandémie
localement et des décisions qui sont
prises par les gouverneurs
il est exact de dire que les états où ça
se gâte un qui se dégradent ce sont des
états des ligier par des gouverneurs
républicains
oui mais en fait je ne jouerai pas cette
carte-là parce que par exemple la
californie reprend aussi et la
californie est aux mains des démocrates
c'est plus géographique alors on peut
faire évidemment un lien entre le fait
que les républicains soient beaucoup
plus représenté dans le centre du pays
et dans le sud est donc c'est
effectivement les zones qui pour
l'instant sont touchés mais de là à dire
que c'est de la faute des gouverneurs
républicains c'est un peu compliqué une
chose est sûre un tsonga pardonnez moi
j'ai mon cou parce que je n'ai pas dit
ça mais c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on
peut lire ici ou là et c'est vrai qu'il
ya une différence de doctrine
on le voit donald trump qui ne porte pas
de masque d'ailleurs c'est un débat dans
le pays on hésite à confiner donc ça
peut-être des conséquences tout de même
d'être républicain ou démocrate dans ce
cas précis de gestion de la crise alors
là vous avez tout à fait raison c'est à
dire qu'il ya une politisation du virus
entre les républicains qui décident
d'une part de nier la gravité de la
pandémie et deuxièmement voire même de
demander d'exiger le déconfinement et
les démocrates qui sont dans une logique
de respect de soutien des directives
sanitaires qui sont prises et il est
vrai que parmi les états qui sont
actuellement les plus touchés en tout
cas les grands états je pense à la
géorgie qui a été le premier état des
confiner la floride et le texas
il y a une responsabilité des
gouverneurs en l'occurrence républicain
qui effectivement sans doute des conf il
est beaucoup trop tôt
alors vous qui êtes à washington comment
cela se passe passe quand on parle
beaucoup effectivement du manque de
civisme de certains
d'autres au contraire qui applique
strictement les règles comment ça se
passe notamment à washington capitale
fédérale washington et les états qui
sont autour respecte énormément les
consignes sanitaires c'est à dire les
gestes barrière la distanciation sociale
en plus washington fait partie dans la
région la ville
le district de columbia fait partie des
seuls endroits où la houle a le nombre
de contaminés continuer à baisser alors
que par exemple en pennsylvanie l'art
commencé à remonter et dans le delaware
on est également une reprise ainsi qu'en
virginie occidentale donc on est un
petit peu un îlot entouré de d'état ou
ça a tendance à reprendre ici les gens
font vraiment attention quand on leur
dit portaient des masques ils portent
des masques quand on leur dit de garder
une distance
il l'a gardée donc ça se passe plutôt
bien alors on est à quatre mois de la
présidentielle américaine évidemment ça
pèse lourdement on imagine sur cette
campagne un joe biden de le disait
lui-même joe biden qui me frappe à deux
meetings avant cette présidentielle
c'est un pari risqué selon vous pour le
candidat démocrate
non je ne crois pas je baille donne joue
vraiment la carte de du respect absolu
des règles c'est à dire que il a rendu
hommage au docteur anthony fauci hier en
disant que si jamais il était élu
président il le garderai donc le fameux
chef de la task force coronavirus de la
maison blanche que vous avez cités tout
à l'heure dans votre reportage il est
dans une logique de respect total est
donc dans la logique de cette de ce
respect est bien il a décidé d'ajourner
les d'annuler les les manifestations les
meetings qu'il avait prévu c'est à dire
que les grands moments de la campagne
qui va se dérouler c'est d'une part la
convention démocrate et d'autre part
évidemment les trois débats qui sont
prévues avec donald trump d'ici au 3
novembre
est-ce qu à l inverse le rebond
l'épidémie fragilise encore davantage
donald trump qui a vécu cette séquence
compliqué aussi avec les manifestations
contre les violences policières
écouter absolument parce que donald
trump a fait un pari c'est celui de la
relance de la delà de la machine
économique américaine le plus rapidement
possible pour retrouver les standards
qui étaient ceux de l'économie us au
début de l'année avant la pandémie
or la deuxième vague parce que là on
peut véritablement parler de deuxième
vague
contrarie complètement ses plans en
l'occurrence il ne trouve pas la réponse
adéquate celle qui rassure en
particulier son électorat c'est à dire
les seniors les plus de 65 ans de 70 ans
qui sont évidemment ceux qui sont les
plus menacés par le par le corona virus
donc il a un vrai problème politique qui
peut si le corona virus poursuit lui
poser énormément de problèmes pour le
mois de novembre
c'est son électorat qui est touché ce
sont les zones dans lesquelles il est
fort où les républicains sont forts qui
sont des zones où ils sont qui sont
touchés et dont il est effectivement
actuellement sans réponse véritable pour
se rassurer son électorat
merci beaucoup les capitons avocat au
barreau de washington d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france merci et ce
afin dé contenus haineux sur internet
facebook en tout cas commencent
seulement à durcir le ton et annonce
aujourd'hui deux nouvelles règles contre
les propos racistes diffusée sur son
réseau social
la décision sous pression il faut le
dire prise après le boycott inédit de
400 marques contre le géant du web lé
plus de précision avec ilan a fait radio
c'est l'heure du grand ménage pour
facebook
coca cola ben & jerry's lévis plus de
400 grandes marques ont annoncé l'arrêt
temporaire ou prolongée de leurs
investissements publicitaires sur le
réseau social
la raison une campagne de boycott lancé
le 17 juin dernier par plusieurs ong et
associations de lutte contre le racisme
comme l'anti defamation league
intitulée stop wait for profite stopper
la haine pour le profit en français elle
vise à mettre fin aux contenus haineux
sur facebook
dans un long texte publié sur le site de
la campagne les organisateurs détail
leurs démarches
les réseaux sociaux ont permis à la
haine et à l'extrémisme de se propager
plus rapidement que jamais chaque jour
nos organisations sont alertés par de
nombreux exemples de messages de haine
et de désinformation diffusé sur
facebook est soutenue par des publicités
payantes
face à la grogne le mouvement pourrait
pousser
certaines entreprises françaises et
européennes à suivre la tendance une
prise de conscience collective qui
frappe le réseau social au coeur pour
rappel facebook profite aujourd'hui de
quelques 8 million d'annonceurs une
véritable manne financière comme
l'indiquent le film sur le times
selon les données des marketeurs
facebook devrait générer 80 1 milliards
de dollars de revenus publicitaires
annuelles ce qui suggère qu'il engendre
environ 4,7 milliards de dollars sur une
période de trois semaines en moyenne
des sommes qui ne sont pas négligeables
pour facebook qui de son côté semble
avoir pris les choses en main le combat
contre la désinformation et les discours
et ne devrait désormais figurer au coeur
des priorités des modérateurs
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le pdg de
l'entreprise mark zuckerberg société
nous adoptons donc aujourd'hui de
nouvelles politiques pour interdire une
catégorie plus large de contenus haineux
dans les publicités
plus précisément nous allons élargir
notre politique en matière de publicité
afin d'interdire les affirmations selon
lesquelles des personnes d'une race ou
d'une ethnie d'une origine nationale
d'une affiliation religieuse d'une caste
d'une orientation sexuelle d'une
identité sexuelle ou d'un statut
d'immigration spécifique ou toute
affirmation selon laquelle elle
constitue une menace pour la sécurité
physique la santé ou la survie de toute
autre personne
preuve de cette bonne volonté ce mardi
un réseau américain d'extrême droite qui
proliféraient depuis 2012 avec des
centaines de comptes à caractère haineux
a été banni de facebook peut-être une
bonne nouvelle à l'heure où la
désinformation est susceptible de
gangréner la campagne pour la
présidentielle américaine de novembre
alors la liberté d'expression est elle
finalement menacé sur les réseaux
sociaux les géants du web sont ils des
censeurs ou rendez battre nous sommes
avec florian philippot président du
parti les patriotes bonsoir florian
philippot merci d'être avec nous avons
côté julie garnier oratrice nationale de
la france insoumise bonsoir avoue julie
garnier merci d'être là également on l'a
entendue dans le sujet
au total 400 marques et pas les moindres
qui ont décidé de cesser leurs
publicités pour protester notamment
contre facebook puisque c'est ce réseau
social qui visait clairement qui est
jugé trop tolérants envers les prises de
paroles racistes insultante ou violente
c'est votre avis à vous aussi julie
garnier il fallait stopper
facebook est beaucoup trop tolérant je
crois qu'on pose pas le sujet de la
bonne façon
concernant facebook et puis là vous
parlez d'une histoire qui se passe aux
etats unis
aux états unis vous voyez qu'on attend
du cafard de facebook entre autres de
faire la justice moi je ne pense pas que
ce soit aux gaffes à de faire la justice
je pense que c'est à la justice de faire
la justice en france on a eu un peu le
même équivalent avec la loi à bien vous
savez qui a été d'ailleurs retoqué parce
que ce n'est pas aux gaffes à facebook à
twitter et c'est de dire ce qui peut
être dit ou ce qu'il peut pas pour ça on
a des choses qui s'appelle des lois et
ce sont des lois républicaines et
uniquement de justice républicaine
peut être peut dire ce qui peut dit et
ce qui ne peut pas affectivement
pardonnez moi je vous ai coupé parce
qu'on vous vous disiez ça se passe aux
etats-unis mais c'est beaucoup de
marques européennes qui sont en train de
couper les publicités donc ce n'est pas
un problème purement américain ça
concerne notamment facebook france pour
la france donc ça prend de l'ampleur
florian philippon ne prend pas le
problème dans le bon sens vous trouviez
vous en tout cas facebook trop tolérant
c'est le seul réseau social qui par
exemple ne censure pas donald trois en
tout cas ne note pas des remarques sur
ses sweats par exemple contrairement aux
autres réseaux sociaux
non mais attendez là on parle de
multinationale nike coca cola etc
vous pensez qu'elles ont quelque chose à
faire honnêtement des propos haineux des
propos racistes c'est évidemment un coup
de pub c'est évidemment la pression des
concurrents qui fait que chacun n'a plus
le choix se sentent obligés d'annoncer
qu'ils vont répartir cette opération de
suppression de publicité sur facebook
sur les réseaux sociaux et ses marques
la non strictement rien à faire de tout
cela elles sont juste là pour faire de
l'argent et elle ferait mieux d'ailleurs
de s'intéresser à la manière dont elles
traitent leurs salariés dans l'âme à
nantes elle exploite des raisons des
enfants dans leurs usines du tiers monde
parce que pendant qu'on parle de cette
infernale s'achète une bonne conscience
à peu de frais
et ça leur permet de continuer leur sale
boulot environnementales sociales et
compris contre certains enfants ou des
lieux des personnes maltraitées dans le
tiers monde il ya beaucoup de rapports
de hennezel éthique sous l'étiquette par
exemple le cas pointé du doigt à taipei
en 2018 et tant d'autres où adidas
donc franchement moi je n'attends pas de
ces boîtes l'as trouve que c'est
extrêmement dangereux que ces batna
s'érigent en justiciers de la liberté
d'expression quant à la sphère de donald
trump twitter a déjà un modéré plusieurs
fois ses tweets
moi je suis désolé qu'on soit d'accord
ou pas avec donald trump lui les élus il
est chef d'état des présidents d'une
démocratie que certains des états unis
un réseau social privé se permettent
selon des critères ou des algorithmes de
bidouiller de modérer la parole d'une
personnalité élue chef d'état je trouve
que c'est une dérive grave estime quoi
qu'on pense encore une fois de n'importe
quelle déclaration de n'importe quel
chef d'état élu démocratiquement
je trouve que c'est extrêmement va et
occupant et ça doit tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé si tous ceux qui défendent la
liberté d'expression est tout simplement
la démocratie jeu les gars y est ce que
vous partagez le diagnostic de florian
philippot alors on précise que ce ne
sont pas que des des grosses
multinationales américaines le danois
lego a rejoint ses autres marques coca
unilever il ya un européen volkswagen
qui a également coupé ses budgets
aujourd'hui l'oréal
il ya quelques jours on en parle et
voilà alors ça c'est un autre débat mais
c'est vrai que là on supprime le côté
blanchissement blanc sur ces produits
selon-vous julie garnier est ce que ces
marques là elle cède à une forme tout
même de de pression vous n'avez pas
cette lecture je crois que l'enjeu n'est
pas au delà des seules marques vous
savez la censure sur les réseaux sociaux
il existe et nombre de concitoyens
ressentent une véritable censure sur les
réseaux et on peut dire que le climat
lors donne plutôt raison on voit que des
jackets liberté en général est attaquée
je pense à la liberté manifester est la
liberté et exprimé je vous rappellerai
quand même que pendant le confinement
une femme a eu droit à une garde à vue
juste pour avoir mis une pancarte macro
navires us à sa fenêtre
donc vous voyez que les libertés elles
sont fortement attaquées quand même et
il faut s'en inquiéter
mais j'ai envie de regarder de manière
c'est un peu plus large c'est à dire
qu'elles sont attaquées par notamment
une certaine pensée une certaine
oligarchie dominante qui voit dans ces
réseaux sociaux et bien finalement
l'opportunité pour bon nombre de
citoyens de pouvoir s'exprimer et de
pouvoir trouver une information qui ne
trouvent pas sur les médias dominants et
il est peut-être là le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a des médias dominants
qui sont structurés qui est structurant
et qui donne une influence sur ce qu'on
doit penser ce qu'on doit pas penser et
c'est peut-être ça aussi le souci qu'il
faudrait souligner et je pense notamment
à certaine censure qui existent sur les
médias
je ne citerai que quelques exemples mais
pour illustrer le propos je vous
rappelle quand même qu'une enquête sur
crédit mutuel avait été censuré par
bolloré qu'une autre enquête sur les
aviez neil avait été censurée sur m6
donc vous voyez que il y à des censures
qui existe et je trouve que dans ces
réseaux sociaux quand on veut les
attaquer j'y vois une certaine façon de
mettre de côté finalement une pensée
dans la pensée des citoyens la pensée du
peuple et ça c'est plutôt inquiétant une
certaine but des classes finalement où
on voit une oligarchie dominante des
bourgeois dominant qui veulent va dire
ce que vous les autres doivent penser
s'est retrouvée qu'avec les réseaux
sociaux en tous les cas facebook un ca
obtempérait si j'ose dire parce qu'il a
commencé à durcir le ton aujourd'hui un
vrai changement
le réseau social a banni google ou un
hymne ans violents d'extrême droite de
son réseau fermé 220 compte au contenu
haineux florian philippot votre réaction
à la réaction facebook facebook mais
écoutez vous savez les citoyens ils
iront ils iront inventer autre chose et
iront à liart voilà tout simplement et
il va se retrouver finalement être tous
sur des réseaux peut être qu'à la fin on
sera tous sur des réseaux russes chinois
ou peut-être même nord-coréens ont sais
pas ils sont peut-être joue plus libre
que nos propres réseaux des soi disant
démocraties occidentales qui sont en
train de devenir de véritables d'enfer
qu'est ce que c'est que cette ces pays
dans lesquels on vit on a plus loin de
rien dit on a pu y aura de rien penser
on n'a plus droit de alors on sait pas
ce qu'on va vexé une telle ou telle
minorité agissante qui plein de haine et
pleines de ressentiment qui peuvent vous
envoyer devant la justice à tout moment
si elle estime qu'un amour vous auriez
dit ne lui a pas plu il aurait pu aurait
pu vexer la pensée de ses ancêtres il ya
500 ans
qu'est ce que c'est que cette société
complètement dingue ou en supprime le
démo ou l'oréal qui prime le
qui clair vous imaginez on nous aurait
dit ça il ya dix ans l'aurait pas cru on
l'aurait pas cru t'annoncer stupide or
on est plus à l'oréal là on est dans un
état psychiatrique on déboulonne des
statines où on agresse c'est cette nuit
de de gaulle et on écrit dessus et
scénariste de gaulle esclavagiste pas
faut être cinglé si on sait que le
niveau de culture générale s'est
effondrée dans notre pays et dans nos
pays occidentaux que notre l'occident et
d'en détenir un manifeste et on a
tendance à me le prouver mais quand même
donc là on s'attaque à la liberté
d'expression
on s'attaque à la liberté de pensée la
conscience des hommes et des femmes
c'est gravissime et tout ça par des
boîtes qui sont là pour faire du fric et
qui sont là pour nous octroyer quand
elles le souhaitent un peu de liberté et
nous a retiré quand elles le souhaitent
également sans jamais que la justice ni
l'état de droit ne puisse s'exprimer
moi je trouve ça fera le plus grave
c'est que les états et les soi disant
démocratie comme la france accompagne le
mouvement 1 ce qui effectivement s'il
n'y avait pas eu de la censure du
conseil constitutionnel
dès aujourd'hui le 1er juillet on aurait
appliqué l'odieux loi via c'est à dire
qu'on aurait tous eu des gros boutons
quand on serait allé sur twitter
facebook ou youtube on aurait pu
dénoncer le voisin ou dénoncer tel ou
tel vidéo pour la faire supprimer dans
les 24 heures
c'est ça ce que nous promettait le
gouvernement de nacre où il accompagne
en réalité facebook et tous les censeurs
ben moi je trouve ça grave je pense
qu'il faut beaucoup plus de liberté il
ya beaucoup plus d'intelligence quand
hier plus de liberté oui quand il ya
plus de liberté peut aussi avoir des
sottises voir des horreurs mais il peut
y avoir et il y aura aussi plus
d'intelligence par contre quand la plus
de libertés et quand il n'ya plus que de
la censure vous pouvez être certain
qu'il n'ya plus que de la bêtise et il
n'y a plus rien d'intelligent qui se dit
dans ce monde je les gardais vous voyez
saurait réagir prendre des notes
non mais juste monsieur philippe on
oublie un peu l'histoire en fait le fait
de déboulonner les statues de débaptiser
des rues ça se fait pendant toute
l'histoire en fait et ça c'est une
historienne qui vous pas c'est à dire
que l'histoire et la mémoire est quelque
chose qui se rend visite à chaque fois
d'ailleurs sa porte mais maman c'est une
science ça s'appelle historiographie
voilà donc l'histoire elle serait écrit
et c'est logique c'est même sein de
pouvoir revoir les mémoires et c'est ça
se fête voilà ça c'est vous savez que
tous les ans des bâtisses des rues et ça
ne choque absolument personne par contre
il faut pas non plus être mélangés
malheureusement on voit aussi qu'il y a
une certaine parole qui se libèrent et
là je pense notamment à un chroniqueur
que vous devez peut-être bien connaître
monsieur zemmour qui qui est
régulièrement tous les jours sur sur une
chaîne de grande ampleur quand même et
qui peut déblatérer sas et ses horreurs
sans que personne ne lui dit absolument
rien ça aussi c'est une c'est une c'est
une catastrophe parce que quelque part
le débat n'est pas posée de manière
sereine
on voit que quelqu'un qui a été condamné
plusieurs fois pour incitation à la
haine
aujourd'hui peut trouver une tribune
facile et ça je trouve aussi que c'est
un souci et je pense que je vous le
disais en préambule je crois que c'est
là dessus qu'il faut insister seule la
justice peut dire on s'arrête et on
commence la liberté d'expression on a
les lois elles sont faites pour ça et
aujourd'hui si elle ne s'acquitte pas
c'est justement parce qu'on manque de
justice que je pas que les citoyens
grecs comme ça en prenait de la justice
du débat serein de la démocratie et
aujourd'hui on constate qu'on en manque
cruellement
et c'est pour ça peut-être que les
débats se chauffe alors qu'ils ne le
devraient pas parce que les conditions
démocratiques tout simplement ne sont
pas réunies ce n'est pas le mot de la
fin est votre réponse à achever les gars
et deux sujets le nom ça choque le
déroulement des statuts vous dites ça
s'est toujours fait non ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'historiographie ce sont des
cinglés qui se permet de jeter de la
peinture sur les statues du général de
gaulle le général de gaulle j'espère que
vous savez qui c'est c'est celui qui
nous a qui a fait l'appel du 18 juin à
la résistance ils ont jeté des parties
mort contre lui
ils veulent déboulonner tous ces gens là
y compris fédère des compresseurs et
compris colbert et y compris napoléon ça
c'est la haine de la france ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'historiographie ce sont
des voyous qui prend 5 pour leur place
derrière les barreaux de prison
quant à zemmour les débats contre lui
allez débattre contre lui s'il n'est pas
d'accord mais nous dit pas d'un côté que
vous êtes pour la liberté d'expression
et d'autres côtés de secondes plus tard
vous appelez à la censure d'eric zemmour
sur ses news
soit c'est le soigne et cohérente à les
débattements produits ou si vous n'y
allez pas c'est peut-être que vous
n'avez peur de pas être au niveau
à mon avis vous non pas au niveau le
petit mot de la fin je veux les gagner
peut-être parce que vous avez été
interpellé maintenant très rapidement si
vous le voulez bien merci à vous non
juste pour éviter non je suis j'étais
habitué un petit peu plus élégant de la
partition philippot je pense que jusqu'à
rich
tueur et le débat n'est pas à la hauteur
je voyais c'est de ça dont on a besoin
de vrais des vagues pour poser les
choses là c'est juste historiens qui
vous parlent quant à monsieur zemmour
écoutez si cela ne vous pose aucun
problème que quelqu'un puisse dire que
la couleur vert quel rapport avec
l'islam
moi je pense que ça fait juste remonté
des sombres souvenirs et je vous invite
sérieusement revoir vos cours d'histoire
mais juste on peut le dire mais vous
avez le droit de dire que vous n'êtes
pas d'accord moi je vous laisse le droit
à tout le monde de dire qu'on est
d'accord ou pas d'accord je demande
simplement que tout le monde ait le
droit de parler vous voyez la différence
entre nous moi je suis pour le débat y
compris que vous ayez un débat acharné
avec zemmour mais pas que vous censurer
les émaux parce que vous ne l'aimez pas
là c'est autre chose
en tout cas vous avez des bêtes fait
tous les deux voilà pas de pas de
censure sur rt france vous avez des
bêtes chez tous les deux merci à vous
deux florian philippot et julie garnier
d'avoir été avec mon merci à vous dans
quelques instants rester avec nous nous
parlerons du controversé plan paix
américain pour le proche orient le
gouvernement israélien devrait se
prononcer à partir d'aujourd'hui sur la
mise en oeuvre de ce projet et puis nous
parlerons de l'otan en raison de
tensions avec la turquie la france a
temporairement suspendu sa participation
aux opérations surveillance en
méditerranée
[Musique]
on
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france 20h30
heure de paris en russie on vient de
l'apprendre selon les premières
estimations 73 % des citoyens ont voté
pour le projet de réforme
constitutionnelle et devrait permettre
appelé l'émir continue d'effectuer deux
mandats supplémentaires à partir de 2024
pour cette grande consultation populaire
la participation serait de 64 99 %
depuis jeudi dernier les russes étaient
invités à se prononcer par référendum
sur le projet de réforme
constitutionnelle voulue par le
président un scrutin étalé sur plusieurs
jours pour éviter une trop forte
influence en pleine pandémie
des milliers de palestiniens manifestent
en ce moment à gaza contre le plan de
paix américain pour le proche orient ce
projet prévoit l'annexion par israël de
colonies en cisjordanie occupée et de la
vallée du jourdain le gouvernement
israélien devrait se prononcer
aujourd'hui sur sa mise en oeuvre depuis
plusieurs semaines les dirigeants
palestiniens appellent la communauté
internationale à rejeter ce plan
mais les députés allemands viennent
aussi de rejeter l'idée dans le même
temps de sanctions contre l'état hébreu
les explications de romy andrew avec lmh
et medjahed la palestine n'est pas à
vendre et le plan trump ne passera
jamais des dizaines de pancartes barrées
de ses slogans ont vu le jour en
cisjordanie
parmi les événements marquants un grand
rassemblement à jéricho en présence de
nombreux diplomates qui se sont succédé
à la tribune un message fort pour les
palestiniens qui attendent aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus que des mots c'est un plan
qui s'opposent aux droits fondamentaux
des palestiniens
c'est pourquoi nous nous mobilisons vous
voyez ici nous sommes des milliers de
tout le territoire et de toutes les
tendances politiques
c'est encourageant de voir que beaucoup
nous soutiennent aussi l'union
européenne l'onu la russie le japon
la chine tous ces pays considèrent que
nous avons des droits légitimes au
regard du droit international
nous ne souhaitons pas la destruction
d'israël mais uniquement que l'on
respecte nos droits jéricho est la
capitale de la vallée du jourdain
plaines fertiles qu israël souhaite
notamment annexée sur ses terres la
plupart des agriculteurs cultivent les
dates et le raisin des produits pour
moitié destinée au marché local et pour
l'autre revendu à l'international ismail
ayed promet de défendre les territoires
palestiniens jusqu au bout on ne partira
pas même si je dois mourir je ne
partirai pas même si je dois manger de
la terre je ne partirai pas on a laissé
notre terre une fois en 48
on ne va pas le refaire personne ne va
partir
même s'il pleut on va creuser des puits
avec nos mains ismaila y est comme
beaucoup d'autres gardent espoir et se
bat malgré 53 ans d'occupation de la
cisjordanie par israël depuis les
colonies israéliennes s'étendent des
colonies pourtant illégales selon le
droit international un port en parler
non sens en direct depuis tel aviv avec
paula slayer journalistes rt
internationale c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir pour la salière merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
des milliers de palestiniens qui
manifestent dans la ville de gaza
aujourd'hui contre ce plan américain
clairement peut-on craindre une escalade
effectivement plusieurs milliers de
palestiniens manifestent en cisjordanie
également à gaza
les nombres n'ont pas atteint les
attentes sans doute parce que l'annexion
n'a pas été annoncée certaines personnes
craignent que lorsqu'elle sera annoncée
par le premier ministre israëlien
benjamin tanus et pourrait y avoir une
escalade
j'ai demandé à beaucoup d'experts sur
place et il ne pense pas que cela sera à
l'échelle d'une troisième antifa daoud
une révolution palestinienne cela
correspondra sont plutôt à des
manifestations de l'échelle qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui il y à quelques temps
lorsque les américains on transférait
l'ambassade de tel aviv à jérusalem
bien sûr la violence reste une
préoccupation et aujourd'hui c'était une
journée où on a appelé à la colère alors
vous l'avez dit à ma gamine netanyahu ne
s'est pas encore prononcée certains
espèrent on sait pas si c'est un voeu
pieux pour eux qu'il puisse reculer
ça peut être une piste où il ya une
autre raison pour laquelle il ne s'est
pas encore prononcée
à des pâquis le recul depuis le début il
a dit que l'annexion se ferait à partir
du 1er juillet qu'il se tournerait vers
le parlement où le cabinet israélien
qu'il allait mettre ce sujet sur la
table pour qu'il vient vote l'apathie
connexion elle même aurait lieu le 1er
juillet mais à partir du 1er juillet il
n'aurait pas intérêt à ne pas demander
l'annexion parce que l'année dernière
nous avons eu trois élections en israël
et à chaque élection et benjamines à
dinard où a promis une annexion
il perdrait beaucoup de sa légimité
comme légitimité politique et de son
pouvoir politique ici ils reculaient
maintenant ailleurs il ya aussi une
élection ailleurs à aux états unis dans
quatre mois
si joe biden pince on imagine que ça ne
sera pas le même soutien pour benyamin
netanyahou il faudrait peut-être qu'ils
aillent vite
je suis tout à fait d'accord c'est
effectivement le sentiment ne serai
jamais un netanyahou est ainsi départ
les élections en novembre aux états unis
à agir je by dane a déjà déclaré qu'il
ne supporte pas qu'il ne soutient pas
l'annexion et le premier ministre
israélien a déclaré à plusieurs reprises
israël a en le président américain
donald trump son meilleur ami de
l'histoire donc ici il doit y avoir une
élection alors elle de se faire
rapidement alors une annexion en tout
cas qui est jugé illégal par la
communauté internationale à commencer
par l'onu à michelle bachelet qui dit
l'élection est illégal point final la
communauté qui rejette donc ce projet
d'annexion mais qui ne fait finalement
pas grand-chose concrètement contre
puisque j'en veux pour preuve les
députés allemands qui viennent de dire
dans une résolution que les menaces
contre israël seraient finalement contre
productive
ça veut dire quoi comment doit-on
entendre cela
l'union européenne s'est également
exprimée à ce sujet c'est le partenaire
commercial le plus important d'israël et
elle a déclaré qu'elle utiliserait des
moyens diplomatiques pour décourager
l'annexion la communauté internationale
a été très claire elle est contre
l'annexion et la considère effectivement
comme illégales en vue du droit
international
la question c'est quelles seront les
actions de la communauté internationale
qui peut imposer des sanctions
elle peut rejeter mettre au ban israël
est peu marquée des produits venant des
colonies israéliennes en dix ans qui
viennent cultivant de colonies et
netanyahu est très conscient des
critiques et de la condamnation de la
communauté internationale et du fait que
cela pourrait rendre la vie plus
difficile à israël alors il ya une autre
conséquence effectivement de ce plan
c'est que ça fait voler en éclats la
solution à deux états a voulu notamment
par l'europe et par bon nombre
d'observateurs il est clair que cette
annexion éteindra tout espoir n'est ce
pas
qui l'on demandait si l'on parle aux
palestiniens par les israéliens et nick
et de la gauche ils disent effectivement
cela détruit tout espoir pour une
solution à deux états pour un retour aux
négociations entre les palestiniens et
israéliens
mais si l'on balle au soutien de
benjamin netanyahu c'est la majorité des
israéliens
si l'on parle aux électeurs de droite en
israël ils disent que le plan de paix de
donald trump est la meilleure chance
pour un retour aux négociations entre
les deux parties une partie intégrante
du plan de donald trump c'est le
versement de 50 milliards de dollars aux
palestiniens pour renforcer leurs
économies et la reconnaissance d'un état
palestinien
ce sont des bonnes choses pour les
palestiniens eux disent qu'ils n'étaient
pas présents à la table des négociations
que ils n'ont pas été consultés que les
états unis ne sont pas un partenaire
neutre et pour eux le plan américain
c'est le dernier clou dans le cercueil
des négociations israélo palestiniennes
merci pour la flyer d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui certains internationale
pour évoquer donc cette situation
actuellement en israël et dans les
territoires palestiniens merci à vous
dans un contexte de tensions avec ankara
notamment autour du conflit libyen paris
tente de faire pression sur l'otan la
france annonce son retrait temporaire de
l'opération de sécurité maritime si
guardian une opération de l'organisation
transatlantique qui se déroule en
méditerranée cette décision fait suite à
un incident naval survenu le 10 juin au
large de la libye entre une frégate
française et une frégate turque
la france est désormais des réponses de
l'otan concernant ces frictions avec la
turquie et pourrait vite se chamaillent
ancien colonel de l'armée de l'air et
stratège les etats unis ont plutôt
intérêt à soutenir les turcs que les
français les etats unis jouent un jeu
bizarre tout comme les turcs eux
d'ailleurs les durs que joue un jeu très
bizarre les états unis essayent de
maintenir les turcs eux
dans leurs corps tandis que la turquie
sur une trajectoire de moyen terme
je dirais et va plutôt vers la sortie de
l'otan donc je pense qu'effectivement
les etats-unis ont un gros intérêt à
soutenir plutôt et turcs que la france
puisque la france de toute façon et
surtout elle ne prend pas pour grand
chose sur la scène internationale
actuellement tandis que la turquie avec
la charade et s-400 avec probablement
l'achat de 57 à la russie plus tard
puisqu'elle ne pourra plus avoir les 35
tant mieux pour elle donc la nature qui
comme je vous disais est sur une
trajectoire de sortie du camp occidental
et se rapproche de la russie se
rapproche de la chine
donc les états unis ont tout intérêt à
mener une politique qui tente de
maintenir la turquie mais le torchon
brûle entre pékin et washington à
l'annoncé de l'entrée en vigueur de la
très controversée loi sur la sécurité
nationale qui vise à étendre les
pouvoirs de la justice chinoise à hong
kong alors que le pays connaît depuis un
an dans une crise politique sans
précédent
bassem chine c'est une nouvelle loi bien
controversé qui n'en n'a pas fini de
faire parler d'elle et notamment dans
les rangs américains signée jean ping
cette loi adoptée par le comité
permanent du parlement chinois est
accusé par ses détracteurs d'être
liberticide et de constituer un moyen
pour pékin de museler l'opposition
promulguée en kong un peu avant minuit
mardi 30 juin par la chef de l'exécutif
qui a ri l'âme
cette nouvelle loi sur la sécurité
nationale étant les pouvoirs de la
justice chinoise en matière d'atteinte
grave à la sécurité nationale menaçant
de prison à vie tous crimes portant
atteinte à cette dernière
cette loi permet de réprimer quatre
types de crimes contre la sécurité
nationale à savoir les activités
subversives la sécession le terrorisme
ou encore la collusion avec des forces
étrangères
il n'aura pas fallu plus pour susciter
l'indignation d'une partie de la
communauté internationale et washington
en tête
alors que pas moins de 27 pays du
conseil des droits de l'homme de l'onu
parmi lesquels la france l'allemagne ou
encore le japon ont condamné cette loi
mais face à eux un groupe de cinquante
trois pays ont apporté leur soutien à
pékin en saluant l'entrée en vigueur du
dispositif et en estimant que cette
question ne devait pas être discutée au
conseil des droits de l'homme le chef de
la diplomatie américaine mike pompéo à
guy menacer l' empire du milieu de
nouvelles sanctions déplorant je cite un
jour triste pour hong kong et pour tous
les amoureux de la liberté en chine les
etats unis ne resteront pas les bras
croisés pendant que la chine englouti
hong kong dans sa gueule autoritaire des
menaces prises très au sérieux par pékin
qui pointe du doigt une nouvelle
tentative d'intimidation et d'ingérence
dans les affaires internes du pays
nous ne vous avons pas provoquer de quel
droit êtes-vous agressifs avec nous
la loi imposée mardi ne regarde pas les
pays étrangers
quant aux pays qui ont déclaré qu'ils
imposeraient de lourdes sanctions à
certains responsables chinois
je considère qu'il s'agit d'une logique
de bandits de son côté le chef de
l'exécutif hongkongais car ilham a mis
en garde washington contre toute
ingérence
alors que pékin a affirmé que ces actes
sont condamnées à échouer alors hasard
du calendrier ou volonté de marquer les
esprits
la date de sa promulgation coïncide avec
le 23e anniversaire de la rétrocession
de hong kong à la chine par la grande
bretagne et pour en parler nous sommes
avec la blanche maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanc chemise
être avec nous en direct sur un écran
savoir l'entrée en vigueur de cette loi
qu'est ce que cela change pour les ont
comblés oui elle ne change pas mal de
choses elle change évidemment les
conditions d'exercice des libertés
publiques puisque cette loi définit
quatre crimes au sens de la loi
le terrorisme le séparatisme
on voit bien de quoi il peut s'agir et
puis deux autres sujets qui sont un peu
plus vague à définir la subversion et la
collusion avec l'étranger cette loi
prévoit aussi deux nouveaux organismes à
hong kong pour dans le fond interpréter
la loi et pour l'appliquer alors le
premier organisme est une commission que
préside rahman car il aime pourquoi pas
une commission de la sécurité à hong
kong mais avec un surveillant général
venu pékin qui donnera la vigne la ligne
du parti
et puis le deuxième encore plus curieux
est un bureau de la sécurité qui sera
composé en réalité d'un jean d'agents
chinois alors bien sûr on sait bien que
ça que à hong kong depuis longtemps
beaucoup de deux services spéciaux
chinois mais là ils auront pignon sur
rue et ils ont même le privilège de
pouvoir interroger en premier les
suspects au titre des quatre chefs d'un
crédit nation que prévoit la loi
un pays deux systèmes
cette loi remet elle en cause ce
principe
écoutez c'est en tout cas ce qu'a dit ce
matin le président le bâtonnier des
avocats de hong kong en disant que
c'était quand même curieux que cette loi
votée hier en urgence par le bureau
permanent de l'assemblée nationale
populaire à pékin et été promulguée
quelques heures plus tard par monsieur
jean ping le président chinois et dans
la nuit avant minuit par madame car
ilham à hong kong
c'est vraiment une procédure expresse et
sans qu'il y ait absolument aucune
discussion oleko c'est-à-dire à
l'assemblée donc on ce qui
aurait normalement dû être le cas de
plus le barreau de hong kong se plaint
se plaignait ce matin de ne pas avoir eu
connaissance du texte précis de la loi
un texte assez long c'est une loi qui
comporte une soixantaine d'articles et
on ne connaît son texte
à hong kong que depuis aujourd'hui c'est
donc déjà quelque chose d'un peu d'un
peu particulier pour l'autonomie
judiciaire dont bénéficie hong kong
depuis sa restitution à la chine en 1997
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui sur le plan
juridique on peut penser qu'il y a une
sérieuse entorse au principe de un pays
deux systèmes
ce n'est pas le cas sur le plan
économique puisque bien entendu on ne
change rien reste à savoir quelle sera
l'interprétation des acteurs économiques
alors les grandes banques comme hsbc ont
déjà dit qu'elle accepte et parfaitement
cette nouvelle loi
mais évidemment un certain nombre de
cadres d'entreprise de jeunes également
ne l'acceptent pas et par conséquent la
conteste mais ils sont tout à fait
conscients du risque qu'il courait en
l'affrontant ni gouvernement puisque
évidemment il serait arrêté et mis en
prison les peines sont très lourdes
jusqu'à la prison à vie avec des
possibilité de remise de peine notamment
pour des nations c'est à dire pour des
noms aussi dénonciation d'autres hong
kong est et aurait violé la loi alors
sacré quand même un climat un petit peu
particulier
alors claude pourquoi la communauté
internationale sont elles si inquiète
je crois que c'est bonnière la
communauté internationale est inquiète
mais elle est divisée vous l'avez
victoire hier tout à l'heure au conseil
des droits de l'homme de genève
d'abord les britanniques puisqu'après
tout c'est les britanniques qui ont
signé les accords avec les chinois les
britanniques qui ont exercé la
souveraineté sur hong kong
à la suite d'un bail de 99 ans que leur
avait consenti l'empereur de chine au
19e siècle
donc les britanniques disent que en
effet cette loi est contraire aux
accords
il avait passé avec les chinois un pays
deux systèmes
et puis les britanniques auront déjà
pris une mesure qui consiste à dire que
les ressortissants de hong kong qui
voudraient émigré au royaume uni seront
en principe les bienvenus alors il ya
des restrictions
il s'agit surtout des gens qui étaient à
hong kong qui avaient déjà un emploi
hong kong avant la restitution à la
chine c'est à dire avant 97 et qu'ils
avaient un passeport intermédiaire entre
le passeport britannique et le passeport
et les documents d'identité locale
mais par ailleurs l'union européenne
hier l'union européenne évidemment s'est
exprimé de façon assez modérée en disant
qu' il y aurait des conséquences et ce
que dit madame ursula von der leyen et
en demandant à pékin de revoir sa copie
ce qui évidemment est sans espoir
et puis les américains ont commencé
également à alors là à mon très
sérieusement les dents merci à tous d'un
blanc fumaison expert en relations
internationales d'avoir été avec nous
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des auditions de marisol
touraine et
roselyne bachelot par la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale et
puis nous reviendrons sur lons qui
virale rem dehibi indiqué pour les
patients atteints de formes sévères de
kobe de 19 les états unis s'empare de la
quasi totalité sa production
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck faire que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
en pleine crise du couronne a vu rouge
après avoir constaté l'incapacité de
l'union européenne à manifester la
moindre solidarité envers des etam
l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone au et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et trop non la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
bien choisi
[Musique]
et
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de nos activités ou les billetteries
sont à l'arrêt l'impact financier est
énorme
ce sera un redémarrage sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
que ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021 il faudra
reconstruire le marché se reprendre à
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
dans le port
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les logiques qui bien
avant que le match ne commence en effet
par sénégal la chloroquine domaniale est
utilisé pendant deux décennies et des
décennies ça pourrait faire sourire les
sénégalais quand j'ai entendu il n'y a
pas de signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas des féminicides
aujourd'hui en france les cours et les
violences existait avant leur
confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre lecture les taux
de firminy side a plus que je t'ai pas
doublé mais bien monté forcément on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres officiels
c'est très difficile bourreau n'est
jamais n'est jamais loin finalement
c'est le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en eût clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violence de nos grandes pas à 3
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité la demande émise il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on me vois pas ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
elle
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur l'apple c'était
vraiment le laboratoire volant qui
montrait que non seulement on pouvait
s'alimenter au solaire non plus on
pouvait être extrêmement efficients sur
le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement est en état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière exponentielle ça
veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoint pour
cette deuxième démission il est 21h
heure de paris tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi 1er
juillet les deux anciennes ministres de
la santé auditionné leur tour cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale mam seul
touraine et roselyne bachelot entendus
sur la gestion des stocks de masques en
france au lendemain de l'audition
d'agnès buzyn les deux femmes se refuse
à donner des leçons à leurs successeurs
sur la gestion de la crise du coc vide
faute de vaccins pour l'instant les
traitements contre le virus sont
plébiscités par mieux l'antiviral reine
des civils dont les états unis on veut
acheter la quasi totalité de
l'approvisionnement mondial
le laboratoire gilead qui en a le brevet
le vent 2340 dollar les 6 en poule pour
un traitement de cinq jours ça c'est
cher à leurs questions qui pourra
vraiment avoir accès à ce traitement
l'argent est-il le nerf de la guerre
sanitaires ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face le virage écologique emmanuel
macron à le chef de l'étrave de l'état
s'est montré volontariste en début de
semaine devant les membres de la
convention climat est engagée pour la
transition écologique une fibre verte à
laquelle une majorité de français ne
croient pas 58% des sondés répondent par
la négative à la question d'un
engagement sincère selon une enquête
d'opinion réalisée par yougov
[Musique]
le ciel se voile a sérieusement airbus
va supprimer 15 mille emplois d'ici
l'été et 2021 alors qu'il était le
numéro un mondial de l'aéronautique dont
5000 postes en france chez air france le
coronavirus est passée par là lui aussi
la compagnie aérienne prévoit de
supprimer près de 7600 poste des plans
sociaux d'une grande ampleur que les
oppositions politiques estiment excessif
est inacceptable
il
les auditions de la commission d'
enquête sur la crise du commis 19 et la
question de la gestion des stocks de
masques se poursuivent et donc cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale et ex
ministre de la santé marisol touraine et
roselyne bachelot était entendu cet
après midi notre reporter katia
techniques étaient sur place
paris sont ouverts le ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé entre
2012 et 2017 a été auditionné durant
deux heures par la commission d' enquête
parlementaire
elle a défendu son bilan selon ai
toujours voulu garder un très haut
niveau de stocks de masques 750 millions
en l'occurrence et ce malgré une
doctrine qui n'était qu'un avis en 2011
puis est devenue une directive en 2013
qui conseillait de sortir de la logique
de stocks massives pour une logique de
flux mais marisol touraine ne le
souhaitait pas elle a donc continuer à
stocker je me propose de l'écouter
j'ai maintenu l'idée qu'il fallait avoir
des stocks importants
pas seulement pour les masquer je vais
revenir dans un instant et c'est la
raison pour laquelle même si certains
d'entre vous vont dire mais pourquoi n'y
avait il pas un milliard de masques et
il y en avait-il que 754 millions il y
avait 7 154 millions de masques à la fin
du mandat
mais lorsque agnès buzyn a pris ses
fonctions bien très rapidement elle se
serait aperçu que les stocks étaient
périmés ou inexistants elle a donc
recommandée mais les stocks n'ont jamais
été reconstitué à la hauteur des
précédents
et puis pourquoi n'at-elle pas su que
ces stocks étaient périmés et bien il ya
un problème de remontée d'informations
marisol touraine a expliqué qu'elle
avait une délégation qui la tenait au
courant très précisément de la quantité
de masques nous avons posé la question à
jouer le sun forget qui députés présents
à cette commission sur la question des
remontées d'informations au sein des
ministères puisque le fait du masque ça
posera un mois je crois un problème de
comment fonctionnent nos administrations
publiques
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans la remontée
d'informations pourquoi est ce que tout
le monde n'est pas collectivement au
courant d'un élément important qui a un
coût financier qui a un coût humain
potentiel cette pelouse plutôt un
problème de qu'est-ce que c'est la
logistique d'êta qu'est-ce que celle que
la communication dans un cabinet
ministériel ou entre peut-être trop de
couches administrative trop agences et
il ya un ministère et le ministre ça
pose plutôt la question profonde de
l'organisation française des structures
d'état française et là je pense qu'il ya
en effet des redondances qui font qu'il
ya des messages qui reste on va ce qu au
lieu d'être diffusées largement roselyne
bachelot ancienne ministre de la santé
et des sports entre 2007 et 2010 a
ensuite été auditionné on se souvient
qu'elle avait été critiqué pour ses
commandes jugées excessives de masques
et de
durant l'épidémie de h1n1 eh bien il est
resté modeste elle a expliqué que le
contexte à l'époque lui était bien plus
favorable qu'au moment du coronavirus il
se trouve qu'elle a multiplié les salves
contre tout et tout le monde c'est à
dire la france un pays infantiliser les
conseils départementaux l'opinion
publique
certains professionnels de santé mais
elle a aussi répondu à une question clé
le concernant la gestion par un ministre
évidemment on pense à agnès buzyn est ce
qu'être ministre c'est être au courant
de tout et bien selon roselyne bachelot
oui quand on est en charge d'un
ministère ou doit tout connaître bien
sûr et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurent jacot béni porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir laurent
rey comédie merci d'être avec nous alors
on a commencé à écouter
effectivement ces auditions depuis
quelques temps et celle d'agnès busin
hier marisol touraine roselyne bachelot
on l'a dit est les écouter c'est la
faute de personne écoutez il va bien
falloir quand même qu'on trouve les
responsables parce que il sera difficile
d'expliquer aux français notamment ceux
qui ont eu des malades dans leur famille
puis ont été atteints eux mêmes par la
maladie comment et qui est responsable
pas de masque pendant là les deux
premiers mois de l'épidémie
pas de test disponible de du cafouillage
dans tous les sens il faut faire blanc
le lundi et noir le mardi un
gouvernement qui ment aux français
clairement on est face à une séquence où
l'état a été submergé par la tâche
incompétents qui sont nés retrouvés à
mentir aux français
eh bien les français ont besoin de
savoir pourquoi ils ont passé deux mois
de leur vie confinée à cause de
l'incompétence de certains et il est
temps de trouver les nombres et les
raisons clairement laurent jacobellis
qu'est ce que vous avez appris vous de
ces auditions sur cette gestion des
masques est-ce que vous avez des débuts
de réponses écoutez on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement l'appareil d'état est
un petit peu lourd est défaillant c'est
à dire que une administration peut
décider de détruire des masques sans que
le ministre soit au courant m s 1
serment il y a aussi une part de
légèreté des ministres beaucoup de
rapports étaient faits signalant que le
stock des masses s'amenuisait et qu'il
fallait le reconstituer signalant qu'en
cas d'épidémie ou de pandémie même il
fallait pouvoir protéger les français et
qu'il est bien évident de constater que
rien n'a été fait donc je pense qu'on
est face à un double problème
une lourdeur de l'administration c'est
vrai qui a du mal à faire remonter
l'info est un vrai problème
d'incompétence de madame du zinc eu de
monsieur verrons par la suite pour vous
agnès buzyn est entre guillemets la plus
coupable dans cette affaire parce que
c'est vrai creuset une baisse l'eau
l'expliquer voilà c'est difficile de se
mettre dans ce contexte d'épidémie que
personne n'a vu arriver il est vrai
c'est difficile effectivement on doit
bien le reconnaître malam musa n'est pas
la seule coupable
vous savez elle a de son propre aveu
prévenu le gouvernement de ce qu'ils
risquaient d'arriver d'ailleurs
l'ambassadeur de france en chine avait
prévenu dès décembre le président de la
république du risque que la france et
les français encourait or rien n'a été
fait cette espèce d'optimisme béat voire
d'incompétence ou de lâcheté a coûté
très cher très très cher aux français
vous savez nous rassemblement national
dès fin janvier nous prévenions qu'il
fallait fermer les frontières notamment
pour interdire aux avions venant de
chine d'acquérir en france cela n'a pas
été fait dès le début février marine le
pen à l'assemblée nationale demande est
la reconstitution des stocks de masques
donc vous voyez qu'il était possible
d'avoir les infos et de prévenir le
gouvernement
rien n'a été fait quelques semaines
après quelques jours après nous
prévenions qu'il fallait testé
massivement les français pour savent pas
qui était atteint du virus et l'isoler
de son environnement
là encore rien n'a été fait nous ne
sommes toujours pas d'ailleurs au nombre
de tests qui avaient annoncé olivier
ferrand il ya quelques mois donc très
honnêtement la légèreté du gouvernement
est en montre du doigt dans cette
affaire
aujourd'hui clairement vous pointez la
légèreté mais pas de volonté
claire de mensonges d'état si bien sûr
qu'il ya eu des mensonges
quand on explique aux français que
mettre un masque est dangereux et peut
apporter le virus comme a essayé de le
faire maladroitement à l'amci bike and
isles porte parole du gouvernement
on ment aux français pourquoi on leur
ment parce que c'est plus simple de leur
dire il ne faut pas de masque que de
leur dire eh bien nous n'avons pas fait
notre boulot
nous ne nous sommes pas approvisionnée
en masques et à cause de nous vous allez
devoir rester deux mois enfermé c'est
une solution de facilité mais les
français ne sont pas dupes
oui il ya eu mensonge oui il ya eu
légèreté oui le problème d'organisation
aujourd'hui on entend beaucoup
d'observateurs on avait l'avocat divisio
hier qui a porté plainte
justement contre plusieurs remises dont
olivier vers an enez muzer nous dire que
finalement cette commission à
l'assemblée nationale n'apporterait
aucune lumière sur rien et qu'il y avait
une forme de connivence est ce que vous
partagez cet avis de l'avocat
il ya toujours une forme de solidarité
entre d'anciens dirigeants qui ont plus
ou moins bien fait le travail et les
nouveaux une forme de d'entr'aide un
petit peu gênante quand on voit dans
quel état l'économie française a été
plongé dans quel état d'isolement un
certain nombre de français sont se
retrouver à cause
je le répète de la compétence du
gouvernement vous ça il faudra faire la
lumière sur tout faudra aussi qu'on nous
explique pourquoi quand en france on a
un chercheur comme le professeur out qui
préconise un protocole de traitement et
bien on ne fait pas les recherches et
les tests nécessaires pour voir si ce
traitement est efficace ou pas c'est
quand même grave c'est à dire qu'on ne
sait toujours pas aujourd'hui si
l'hydroxyde chloroquine prescrites au
tout début des symptômes de la maladie
est efficace ou non il semblerait que
oui si l'on en croit ce qui se passe est
passé à marseille mais aucun test
leproux il ya une vraie forme de
légèreté et on pourrait mettre ça
peut-être peut-être en parallèle avec
les quatre cent cinquante mille euros
qu'on touche et en quelques années les
membres du conseil scientifique chargé
dd le gouvernement quatre cent trente
mille euros qui vient de grands
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
il ya beaucoup de questions à se poser
en tout cas j'ai seulement ça sera
l'objet d'un autre débat suivant pour
vous l'argent at il vraiment été le nerf
de la guerre de cette crise sanitaire il
y aurait beaucoup à dire et à enquêter
sur ce sujet comme l'a suggéré
d'ailleurs celui que vous citiez le
professeur out
il faut comprendre moi je n'accuse
personne mais il faut comprendre il faut
pour comprendre pourquoi on n'écoute
plus favorablement ce qui préconise un
traitement qui coûte 1000 euros que ceux
qui préconisent un traitement qui vaut 2
3 euros comme hydroxy chloroquine oui ça
pose question je ne suis ni scientifique
ni dirigeant de laboratoire donc je ne
peux pas avoir de réponse certaine mais
j'ai des doutes
oui en effet autre fait cet après midi
le coup de gueule de roselyne bachelot
on est un pays infantiliser beau
roselyne bachelot qui tiennent compte ni
l'action certains élus locaux ou des
médecins qui se plaignent d'être son
équipe et vous partagez ce techno strict
de l'ancien ministre mais pas du tout
une fois encore il ya beaucoup de mépris
dans ses paroles notamment pour les
médecins mais je pense aux médecins de
ville aux infirmiers aux infirmières aux
personnels soignants dont beaucoup et
ont été atteints par la copie de 19 par
manque de matériel justement donc
souligner ce manque de matériel demandé
à être mieux aidés par les autorités
c'est tout à fait naturel en cas
d'épidémie c'est pas du tout une
infantilisation dans l'infantilisation
c'est de parler aux françaises et aux
français comme s'ils étaient des
demeurés de leur dire que porter un
masque c'est dangereux de leur dire que
le traitement que ça ne sert à rien par
bon d'être testées pour savoir si on
aime à la demande saas est infantilisé
les français et c'est vraiment cette
arme lac à utiliser le gouvernement je
pense que c'est cela que devrait plutôt
dénoncer roselyne bachelot merci
beaucoup à laurent jacomelli porte
parole du rassemblement national d'avoir
été
avec nous après plusieurs polémiques au
sujet du rêve désirent un antiviral
contre le coc vie de 19 le laboratoire
pharmaceutique américain gilead vient de
fixer le prix du traitement et il est
élevé de 1340 dollars un tarif donc
contesté qui pourrait être accessible
uniquement aux pays riches
alors faut-il être riche pour se payer
un traitement contre le coran navires us
c'est l'objet de notre face à face juste
après ces précisions en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons fixé le prix un seuil
largement au dessous de sa valeur pour
nous assurer que son accès soient larges
et équitable à un moment où les besoins
mondiaux sont urgents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
urgent le président trump sécurisé
l'obtention de plus de 500 milles dose
du traitement hors md y virent pour les
hôpitaux américains jusqu'en septembre
[Musique]
alors cette question qui pourra avoir
véritablement accès à ce traitement
l'argent est-il le nerf de la guerre
sanitaire c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre à nous
soit vous avec laurent alexandre
essayiste et chirurgiens bonsoir laurent
alexandre merci d'être avec nous
à ses côtés bonsoir jérôme marty médecin
généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine il bonsoir à
vous aussi jérôme marty alors docteur
martien vous avez poussé un coup de
gueule lundi soir sur twitter avant de
le commenter je vous propose de le
revoir de l'oreille et côté 2360 dollars
pour cinq jours de traitement partout
dans le monde pour un traitement qui n'a
pas fait la preuve de son efficacité
autorisations demandées par agence
européenne du médicament
on se fout vraiment de notre gueule
alors voilà ça mérite de la clarté
jérôme marty qu'est ce qui vous dérange
le plus dans cette affaire c'est que ce
soit trop cher ou pas assez efficace
non ce qui me dérange c'est que le même
délire pas plus qu'une roxy chlorite le
chloroquine a fait la preuve réelle de
son efficacité
on nous parle d'un traitement qui est un
traitement compassionnel nous parle d'un
traitement qui diminue le nombre de
jours de maladie de quinze jours en
moyenne à 11 jours mais qui n'a
absolument pas de diminuer le taux de
létalité de la maladie en tout cas de
façon très très faible est pas
significative et là on nous vend des
médicaments dont le prix a été fixé sur
le prix de journée moyen de
d'hospitalisation c'est à dire comme il
ya cinq jours de moins
d'hospitalisations on a fait 5 x x le
prix tourne et on a défini de 1360 euros
enfin bon c'est tout ça était du domaine
plus financier que véritablement
médicale laurent alexandre ce diagnostic
effectivement vu comme ça ça semble
choquant très cher et pas nécessairement
efficaces en tout cas nous on fouquet
cité l'ont prouvé alors il faut pas se
monter le bourrichon le rêve désir n'est
quasiment pas utilisée dans le
coronavirus c'est une molécule qui est
très efficace dans l'hépatite c qui est
efficace aussi dans les baux là mais qui
a une efficacité très modérée comme l'a
dit
et très justement mon confrère dans le
coronavirus il y à une diminution de la
durée d'hospitalisation qui n'est pas
nul
et puis il y à une baisse non
significative statistiquement de la
mortalité et on ne peut pas affirmer que
cette différence de mortalité convoi
dans l'étude n'est pas lié à un hasard
statistiques ça dépasse ça n'est pas
certain d'un point de vue statistique
aujourd'hui très peu de gens prescrivent
du rem daisy pire
donc en réalité c'est pas un enjeu
extrêmement important parce que cette
molécule peu efficaces et très peu
prescrite
donc ce n'est pas un enjeu majeur de
santé publique on pourrait s'inquiéter
si c'était un médicament extrêmement
efficace comme sont les médicaments dont
la md et vire dans l'hépatite c ou les
médicaments dans le hiv mais là on a un
médicament peu efficace qui ne sera de
toute façon pas prescrits par rapport à
la ddh roxy chloroquine je suis d'accord
avec mon confrère litres ce clan
kidnappa c'est la preuve de son
efficacité leadership tranquille
effectivement n'est pas cher mais c'est
pas parce qu'un médicament et pas cher
qu'il faut l'utiliser
le prix n'est pas le premier facteur qui
rentrent en ligne de compte le premier
facteur c'est l'efficacité
si on regardait que le prix ont prescrit
ray de la médecine charlatanesques comme
l'homéopathie à nos patients
mais il semblerait à la différence avec
hydroxy chloroquine que la haine d hiver
n'a pas été mis de côté mais au bon il
n'y a pas eu ce débat acharné comme l'a
été cette molécule préconisée par le
professeur raoul tu jérôme marty
justement comment vous expliquer cette
différence entre guillemets de
traitement est ce que d'accord d'abord
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic
des différences de traitement entre les
deux molécules
oui non je suis d'accord avec ce que dit
mon confrère laurent alexandre ce qui
est ce qui est ce qui est très curieux
dans cette affaire m e déservir c'est la
demande d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché par
l'union européenne qui est assez
curieuse parce que comme comme l'a dit
très justement laurent alexandre c'est
un produit qui n'a pas fait la preuve de
son efficacité en tout cas sur la part
diminution de létalité on utilise un
protocole compassionnel c'est à dire
qu'on le donne en dernier recours quand
vraiment on ne peut rien faire d'autre
mais pourquoi vous redéfini à ce moment
là un prix de 2000 360 euros la semaine
pour un peu je veux dire c'est pas la
règle habituelle qu habituellement on va
vous dire ce produit en termes de
recherche a coûté tant en termes de
matériel à côté tant en termes humains à
côté tant en terme de durée a coûté
temps et à partir de là on fait un ratio
et on définit le coût du médicament en
sachant qu' il va toucher dicks partie
de la population et on va voir s'il peut
être pris en charge par les assurances
sociales des pays et c'est là on le
définit en fonction de l'économie fait
en durée d'hospitalisation
c'est rien je veux dire c'est plus de la
poésie que la médecine
un collectif à l'est sont les médecins à
prescrire c'était mur lundi soir dans
une lettre ouverte
l agence du déni du médicament dénonçant
je cite un blanc-seing accordé par l'
agence européenne justement hors md et
vire le collectif demande à l'agent sa
transparence totale sur les données de
pharmacovigilance pour héros deux cyclos
rockin et le même désir
ça veut dire quoi qu' un doute sur
l'honnêteté que les médecins ne
craignent une forme de manipulation au
profit de 2 qui laurent alexandre oh
écoutez franchement je pense vraiment
pas qu'il y ait de corruption à la f10
et aux états unis et à l'agencé
européenne du médicament et dans les
agences nationales du médicament
pourquoi la crainte
cette crainte a émergé parce que quand
il s'est avéré que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine n'était pas efficace
didier rahout pour noyer le poisson a
expliqué qu'il y avait un complot de
gilles ead pour contrer l'hydroxyde
chloroquine à et maîtres lorraine d
élire à la place
en réalité ce n'est pas du tout ce qui
se passe puisque le désir n'est pas
prescrit donc il ya une crainte qui a
été montée en épingle par didier raoul
tu es si vous prenez les vidéos youtube
de didier raoul depuis quelques semaines
il y en a beaucoup qui sont consacrés à
gillet à ça lui permet de faire oublier
le fait que même aux états unis où trump
avait beaucoup beaucoup poussé hydroxy
chloroquine on l'a retiré des
médicaments autorisés dans le colis de
19 et vous imaginez bien que si
l'hydroxyde chloroquine marchait à 120
jours des élections présidentielles 30
n'aurait pas interdit le protocole de
raul tu il n'est pas masochiste qui ne
veut pas perdre l'élection raul tu donc
de pardon trompe donc le fait que les
états unis aient interdit la molécule
prouve bien que ça n'est pas efficace
après que le président ait énormément
poussé la molécule dans un premier temps
quand il a cru que c'était efficace
donc non il n'y a pas de complot contre
l'hydre auxi chloroquine et en faveur du
rhin dvir mais je partage tout à fait le
point de vue de mon confrère marty
l'hydroxyde chloroquine ne marche pas du
tout et lorraine déviera une efficacité
modeste nul sur la mortalité et puis
c'est bhl sur la durée d'hospitalisation
donc leur md et vire dans cette maladie
là contrairement à d'autres maladies
comme l'hépatite c ou c très efficace
leur md et vire n'est pas un remède
extraordinaire c'est une molécule qui
apporte un tout petit plus vous
relativiser mais en tout cas les états
unis ont quasiment acheter l'intégralité
des stocks
jérôme marty vous êtes d'accord avec ce
7e diagnostic de laurent alexandre c'est
didier raoul qui a monté un petit peu
cette polémique
on n'est pas jérôme marty temps donc je
m'aime mais moins que celui du médecin
généraliste du cros place hier il faut
se mettre à notre place où depuis le
début dans cette affaire qu'il a fait
reed roxy plus haut qu'il le désire et
cetera bon eh bien c'est à dire que on
est au milieu des pro et des anti et on
compte les cours et nous on a nos
patients qui tous les jours me demande
est ce que ce médicament est efficace et
ce que je peux le prendre et ce que je
dois en prendre et on est là les
capacités réelles de leur répondre parce
que il n'y a pas eu d'études académiques
d'études formelle sur la base du
protocole qu'avaient défini par exemple
professeur raoult qui nous aurait permis
de dire aux patients non habitée on est
désolé mais ça ne marche pas ou écouter
oui ça marche donc on est dans une
espèce de l'homme
ce land depuis le début avec avec très
peu de possibilités scientifiques de
dire nombre écouter on est certaine ça
ne marche pas donc là pour l'instant
selon pas dire aux patients de toute
façon et ça c'est important c'est que
malheureusement cette affection ne nous
a pas quittés
malheureusement le virus circule
malheureusement il circule même beaucoup
il circule chez des jeunes des jeunes
actifs qui font défendre position
automatique ou asymptomatiques donc on
ne le voit pas il est encore plus
invisible que ce qui pouvait être à une
époque mais ça ne veut pas dire qu' il
ne peut pas exploser un moment ou un
autre et que cette fameuse deuxième
vague de cette fameuse poussée
n'adviendra pas soit pendant l'été soit
après l'été donc il faut continuer à
porter le masque en lieu clos c'est une
affection des lieux clos ce n'est pas
une affection de l'extérieur c'est une
affection en lieu clos et ça il faut
partir de là il faut ouvrir les
connaître il faut aérer et il faut
respecter les mesures barrières et
continuer parce que malheureusement le
virus ne nous a pas quittés et on va
avoir nous médecins sans doute un rôle à
jouer encore important dans les semaines
qui viennent
laurent alexandre c'est important ce que
nous dit j'ai remarqué ou parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup polémiqué
la deuxième vague semble guetter vous
vous êtes justement inquiet aujourd'hui
qu'est la réaction ses propos justement
je suis d'accord avec partie la
probabilité qu'ils aient une deuxième
vague et est relativement forte il y à
une deuxième vague en ce moment même aux
états unis et en israël par exemple il
faut donc être extrêmement vigilant et
c'est pour ça que j'ai trouvé
extrêmement léger la déclaration de raul
qu'il ya un mois expliquant qu'il n'y
aurait jamais de deuxième vague
ce qui pousse les gens à a levé à lever
le pied sur les précautions et sur les
gestes barrières
il n'est pas raisonnable de dire je suis
certain qu'il n'y aura pas de deuxième
vingt quand on est dit raul tu parce que
cela incite les gens à prendre des
risques et on voit déjà dans deux pays
israël et les états unis qui ne sont pas
des pays sous-développés 1
on voit une deuxième vague la deuxième
vague en israël elle est spectaculaire
et elle est à peu près synchrone de
celle qui a eu lieu aux états unis alors
aux états unis on a des différences
entre les différents états mais la
californie l'arkansas l'arizona la
floride ont une explosion exponentielle
du nombre de cas il faut qu'on soit très
vigilant
arrive là bas ça peut tout à fait
arriver chez nous la deuxième vague
merci à tous les deux laurent alexandre
et jérôme marty d'avoir été avec vous
d'avoir débattu ensemble en direct sur
rtl france merci donc quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons du
virage écologique que veut prendre
emmanuel macron pour la suite de son
tâter n'a été non viendront sur le
secteur aéronautique airbus et air
france ont supprimé respectivement 5000
postes et 7500 emplois sur le territoire
pour faire face à la crise du
coronavirus
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qu'un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse cet ordre
mondial on essaie de le faire perdurer
mais on est à la fin d'un modèle qui
était le tout misé sur la dette à la
dette et la relance par la dette ou par
la création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est en imprimant des billets
que vous relancer une économie si on
essaie autant de relancer la croissance
économique s'est fondamentalement on
sait on sait pas faire sans prince on
s'est connus je peux pas continuer à
diffuser des chiffres qui sont
absolument faux
simplement parce que ça arrange monsieur
trump à ce moment là
ses auteurs
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même en
pleine crise du coroner virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des étapes l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone euro et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et trop non la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
bien choisi
[Musique]
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
20h30 heure de paris soyez les bienvenus
en direct sur rt france les français peu
convaincu par le discours écologique des
manuels mais kron lors de la convention
climat selon un sondage yougov pour f
pas 58 % d'entre eux estiment que
l'engagement du président de la
république dans l' amorce de la
transition énergétique n'est pas sincère
autres chiffres issus de la même enquête
66% des sondés estiment que le chef de
l'état n'a pas assez fait pour le climat
lors des dernières dans lors des
premières années de son quinquennat
ils sont seulement 22 % à penser le
contraire et pour en parler nous sommes
avec bruno cautrès politologue chercheur
cnrs au cevipof spécialiste des
comportements et des attitudes
politiques
bonsoir bruno cautrès merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors
c'est vrai que tu es spécialiste des
questions écologiques n'ont pas vraiment
été convaincu par le discours d'
emmanuel macron les français n'ont plus
décidément la suspicion est tenace oui
c'est clair
vous savez les spécialistes de
comportements politiques utilisent
souvent une notion ils disent que pour
que les électeurs croient dans
l'engagement d'un parti politique d'un
candidat dans sa sincérité
il faut qui lui est attribuée avant
cette spécialité
les électeurs vont spéciales vont dire
que la gauche
bah c'est elle qui a qui peut traiter
les questions de justice sociale de
lutte contre les inégalités la droite
avec le business la compétitivité de
l'économie l'ordre public
et lorsque les français pensent écologie
réchauffement climatique questions
environnementales ben il trouve que
c'est plutôt les verts qui s'en occupent
donc on voit qu emmanuel macron à un
challenge qui est extrêmement important
qui ait deux quais de convaincre
effectivement à la fois de la sincérité
mais aussi de la crédibilité de son
engagement économique après tout
emmanuel macron a fixé des objectifs
très ambitieux mais après tout il lui
reste moins de deux ans pour effectuer
ces objectifs dans le cadre d'autres
quinquennat ce que vous décrivez là est
ce que finalement ça s'appelle un
préjugé voilà les verts c'est pour
l'écologie la justice sociale pour la
gauche c'est ce qu'on fait un faux
procès selon vos emmanuel macron si on
va plus loin que d'offres ou un faux
procès après tout emmanuel macron nelly
moins bien ni mieux placé que d'autres
hommes ou femmes politiques pour parler
de l'écologie aujourd'hui tout le monde
parle de l'écologie mais c'est
simplement que les français vont
reconnaître aux écologistes à des
personnalités comme nicolas hulot comme
yannick jadot eelv on les créditer de la
la longueur de leur engagement c'est si
vous prenez quelqu'un comme yannick
jadot ou comme nicolas hulot ils ont
fait l'intégralité de leur carrière
militante de leur engagement dans dans
la sphère publique au service de cette
cause de l'écologie on peut pas dire que
ce soit le cas d'emmanuel macro qui a
d'abord et avant tout voulu incarner à
la fois la compétitivité de l'économie
française de réconcilier la france et
les français avec la la mondialisation
est par ailleurs les français ont quand
même encore en toile de forme en mémoire
le départ de nicolas hulot du
gouvernement emmanuel macron était
arrivé à recruter celui que tout le
monde voulait faire entrer dans un
gouvernement
alors c'est vrai que ça a testé de
l'importance que emmanuel macron accordé
à cet enjeu mais justement on a retenu
qu'il n'a pas su garder eux nicolas
hulot venir quand vous l'avez citer
nicolas hulot c'est peut-être cet
épisode qui a tout changé
effectivement 66 % des français pensent
que le chef de l'état n'en a pas fait
assez notamment pour le climat au début
de son quinquennat c'est là selon vous
que la machine s'est enrayée il ya eu
ensuite le départ tonitruant on ne sait
de françois de rugy une série de
malchances pour voir emmanuel macron sur
le plan de l'écologie
en tout cas c'est clair qu'il ya eu une
séquence très difficile pour emmanuel
macron vous le rappelez vous avez raison
départ de nicolas hulot départ trans rue
de rugy le ministre de la transition
écologique y remplacer nicolas hulot et
puis la crise des gilet jaune qui s'est
faite
initialement au départ sur des questions
de deux taxes qui concernait le diesel
l'essence les 80 km donc on voit que cet
enjeux climatiques environnementales est
un enjeu effectivement sur lequel
emmanuel macron a du mal à trouver son
rythme de croisière
aujourd'hui il nous dit qu'il souhaite
finir ces deux dernières années en
mettant la gomme en allant vraiment très
très très très vite et très loin sur
l'écologie je pense que beaucoup de
beaucoup ce sens et attendent de devoir
à la fois qu'elles seront les
engagements qu'elle quelles seront les
conséquences budgétaires aussi de ces de
ces décisions qui sont attendus le score
des écologistes aux européennes est
évidemment plus récemment aux
municipales le dernière ne sera pas
n'est ce pas oui bien sûr il n'a guère
de choix au fond emmanuel macron a au
cours de son mandat en partie perdu le
soutien du centre gauche qui pourtant
avait contribué de manière absolument
décisive à son élection il a récupéré
une partie du centre droit mais on voit
que pour gagner l'élection
présidentielle se qualifier au deuxième
tour il lui faudra sans doute
reconquérir des parts des lectorats ils
voient sans doute avec quelques
inquiétudes monter progressivement à la
fois le thème de l'écologie mais aussi à
travers les élections municipales on n'a
vu non seulement des victoires de
l'écologie dans certaines des grandes
villes françaises et non des moindres
bordeaux par exemple strasbourg mais
aussi la bienvenue à mon avis à travers
les élections municipales qui était en
train de se mettre en place une nouvelle
dynamique
rose verte et des fois un peu rouge
d'ailleurs autour d'une sorte 2-2
nouvelle union de la gauche municipale
avec un effet d'entraînement des
écologistes et ça je pense que dupont
tenu sa stratégie politique s'inquiète
emmanuel macron justement les
écologistes peuvent devenir des
concurrents sérieux
des challengers sérieux à la
présidentielle aujourd'hui
alors il faut pas tout de suite sauté
pas je pense qu'il ya deux erreurs à ne
pas faire la première erreur serait de
sauter le pas immédiatement des
municipales vers la présidentielle en
disant il ya un bouilloire qui attend
une candidature écologiste l'autre
erreur ça serait au contraire de dire
ces élections municipales le forte
abstention n'étaient que des scrutins
locaux et de veulent revenir au plan
national c'est entre les deux il s'est
passé quelque chose
à travers ces élections municipales et
c'est sans aucun doute autour de ces
questions que emmanuel macron aura sans
doute de la delà de la concurrence il
veut venir sur le thème écologistes et
le thème de l'écologie et je pense que
les les principales forces politiques
qui est également veulent incarner
l'écologie se rappelleront à son bon
souvenir au moment de la présidentielle
merci beaucoup aux locaux 13 politologue
chercheur cnrs au cevipof d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france c'est
un choc pour les salariés des revues
seul le groupe aéronautique européen
prévoit la suppression de 15 postes et
représentants du personnel ont découvert
hier le plan de restructuration et
prévoit ans portant des effectifs en
moins dont le tiers en france
airbus n'est qu'après la crise ducobu 19
un plan jugé excessif par le
gouvernement français mais qui ne tient
pas compte selon le secrétaire d'état
aux transports ce matin les dispositifs
dette de l'état et devrait permettre de
sauver et 2000 emplois
airbus aura à vivre une période très
difficile il faut bien avoir conscience
que la crise dans l'aéronautique est
majeur on n'a jamais vécu une crise
comme cela depuis qu'on a démocratisé
l'aviation ces suppressions d'emplois ne
tiennent pas compte des différents
dispositifs d'état et d'entreprise
l'activité partielle longue durée
qu'airbus va évidemment utiliser
permettra de sauver 1500 emplois on
investit aussi massivement sur l'avion
de demain la nouvelle génération
d'avions verts sobre en carbone
ces 500 emplois sauvés pour airbus soit
2000 au total et de leur côté les
syndicats d'airbus appelle à des
négociations
on est devant un plan social qui est un
conte social massif
et je répète ce que j'ai dit depuis
plusieurs jours cette crise est
conjoncturelle airbus et une entreprise
solide qui a devant elle un carnet de
commandes solide et nous allons faire
des propositions fortes il y a des
possibilités d'abord il y à des
dispositions de chômage de longue durée
qui doivent être engagés
il y a la possibilité de faire partir
les salariés âgés un départ anticipé
il y a la possibilité de former les
salariés il y a la possibilité de
proposer des congés sabbatiques aux
jeunes qui veulent profiter de cette
période pour vivre une autre expérience
puis revenir plus tard ces chiffres ont
été un choc
vous les connaissez peut-être 14 1931
postes supprimés pratiquement cinq mille
en france 4 1952 il faut savoir quand
même que dans cette filière et d'un
virus au mois de mars encore ont recruté
et ont cherché des compétences qu'on
avait du mal à trouver
donc vous êtes trois mois après et vous
supprimez donc voilà plus de 14 ans
pratiquement quinze mille postes et la
france subit aussi de plein fouet les
conséquences de la crise du coronavirus
la compagnie aérienne pourrait supprimer
plus de 7500 postes d'ici fin 2022
les détails du plan de réduction
d'effectifs seront dévoilés vendredi aux
élus syndicaux pour justifier sa
décision la direction met en avant le
fait que le trafic aérien ne reviendra à
la normale en 2023 des départs sur la
base du volontariat ou contraint la
question demeure de nombreux départs en
retraite ne seront pas remplacés
et pour en parler nous sommes avec henri
sterdyniak économiste à l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques et
membre des économistes atterrés
bonsoir henri sterdyniak merci d'être
avec nous excessif hynix et inacceptable
disproportionnée à les oppositions
évidemment sont montés au créneau pour
dénoncer ces suppressions de postes
est-ce que clairement selon vous on
aurait pu les éviter vu le contexte on a
une situation qui est tragique si je
peux dire c'est que on a un secteur
économique l'aviation l'aéronautique qui
va subir très fort ralentissement et
même une décrue de son activité à la
cour à la suite de la crise sanitaire
bien sûr le tourisme va à reprendre un
choc important le il ya des mesures qui
sont prises pour éviter la propagation
de la pandémie qui nuisent au transport
aérien
les préoccupations écologiques faut que
on dit aux gens ne prenaient plus
l'avion prenez le train
tout ça fait que l'activité d'air france
et de nombreuses autres compagnies
aériennes ralenti du coup ils se
retrouvent avec suffisamment et même
trop d'avions et naturellement bas ça
les amène à supprimer annuler des
commandes chez airbus et chez boeing est
donc naturellement ça crée un problème
de sureffectifs et il est très difficile
de régler un problème de sureffectifs
autrement que en réduisant les emplois
alors certains demande même au
gouvernement d'empêcher ancenis
sentiment d'ailleurs bruno l'homme
c'est s'est exprimé là dessus il n'est
vraiment pas chaud pour rodez
licenciements contraints est-ce qu'on
peut carrément les interdire c'est
possible le problème c'est si on
interdit les licenciements que fait-on
des sureffectifs est ce que on va
conserver des gens en disant ma voilà en
fait on n'a rien à vous faire faire donc
c'est pas une solution la solution c'est
la reconversion c'est à dire de dire des
gens qui pensaient travailler dans
l'aéronautique et ben il faut qu'ils
travaillent dans d'autres métiers qui
deviennent enseignants qui deviennent
qui se dit qu'ils se lancent dans le btp
ou dans ou dans le soin à la personne
effectivement c'est tragique mais on
peut pas à la fois dire il faut réduire
des vols qui sont extrêmement coûteux en
termes écologiques et maintenir et
maintenir l'emploi donc le le problème
c'est il faut organiser la reconversion
et ses recettes mais j'imagine voilà
quelqu'un par exemple un pilote qui a
fait des études qui a galéré entre
guillemets pour en arriver là vous lui
dites bâle et être enseignant our vous
reconvertir dans le bâtiment sachant que
c'est pas des métiers non plus très
simple quand on voit la colère sociale
aujourd'hui et les salaires à ses bad et
les professeurs c'est extrêmement
difficile alors l'état ont plus injecter
plusieurs milliards dans le secteur
aéronautique on peut s'interroger
clairement pourquoi ces plans d'une
telle ampleur alors que l'état a injecté
des milliards 7 milliards par exemple
ces 7 milliards sont utiles nécessaires
pour qu'effectivement les entreprises
restructurent qu'elle s'adapte à la
transition écologique
on va lancer des recherches pour avoir
des avions qui sont beaucoup qui sont
beaucoup moins polluant qui émettent
moins de gaz à effet de serre
on se retrouve quand même devant une
période très difficile où ces avions
écologique n'existe pas et où on dit aux
gens et éviter au maximum de prendre
l'avion et donc naturellement ça veut
dire que y'a un problème de sureffectifs
est ce qu'on peut reprocher
effectivement à l'état ou à aux
entreprises de ne pas avoir anticipé
effectivement ce ralentissement de
l'activité aéronautique faut se souvenir
qu'il ya six mois
on voulait se poser la question de du
nouvel aéroport à nantes se posait la
question de vendre un prix extrêmement
élevé aéroports de paris et on prenait
pas prenez pas en compte le fait qu'il
va y avoir transition écologique
c'est-à-dire que secteur par secteur il
faut réfléchir dans quelle mesure mon
secteur est un secteur d'avenir et 6,6 à
secteurs d'avenir
il faut embaucher il faut former si
c'est un secteur qui doit réduire la
voilure naturellement la question se
pose la question se pose différemment a
effectivement on peut réduire le coût
seul le coût social en disant on va
faire du du travail à à temps partiel on
va faire des des congés sabbatiques
mais il faut foncièrement il va falloir
d'une façon d'une autre diminuer
l'emploi et il faut reconvertir de
manière la plus sociale possible avec
des prestations qui permettent de faire
le le 2 qui permettent de maintenir un
certain niveau de vie fort convertir une
partie des effectifs
allez on connaît le taux de chômage en
france en tout cas merci à vous et henri
sterdyniak à d'abord été avec nous en
direct sur rt france merci à
qui sera le nouveau défenseur des droits
hier soir l'elysée avancé le nom de
claire hédon pour remplacer jacques
tombant il s'agit d'une ancienne
journaliste radio à la tête de
l'association atd quart monde pour qui
lutte contre l'extrême pauvreté
après six ans de mandat gèle tout le
monde doit quitter fin juillet ses
fonctions à la tête de l'autorité
indépendante
dressant son bilan hier il insisté sur
les droits fondamentaux des personnes
âgées et n'a pas hésité à critiquer la
décision prise par le gouvernement de
confiner la population il a quand même
vécu un épisode où pendant quelques
jours il paraissait que de gaieté de
coeur on puisse décider dans notre pays
que au dessus d'un certain âge on
resterait enfermer la société ceux en
tout cas qui qui parle pour elle et
peut-être même le commun des mortels
chez nous n'ont pas trouvé aberrant
n'ont pas trouvé antihumain pensé qu'on
pouvait faire ce type d' apartheid
cette personne sans autonomie
dépendantes âgées handicapées
vieillissantes
mais aussi de beaucoup de personnes
précaires qui sont à la merci d'une
société et d'institutions publiques qui
n'ont peut-être pas pour premier réflexe
de se demander comment il faut faire
pour que toutes ces personnes dès
millions
des dizaines de millions ne soient pas
laissés pour compte
direction la belgique à présent l'europe
commence à s'ouvrir pour la saison
touristique beaucoup comptent sur la
période estivale pour relancer
l'activité même si l'épidémie
coronavirus est toujours là les communes
belges du littoral se sont équipés de
caméra intelligente
pour comptabiliser précisément le nombre
d'estivants présent objectif alerter les
autorités et les touristes en cas de
forte affluence
raphaël blanc d'amour avec françois
xavier lambert sur les plages de la côte
flamande les distances de sécurité sont
pour l'instant facile à respecter
seuls quelques vacanciers profitent d
eau fraîche de la mer du nord et
peaufinent leur bronzage et c'est
justement pour se préserver de tout
afflux massif cet été que l'office de
tourisme flamand a pris les devants il a
équipé les communes de la côte de
caméras dites intelligentes
un dispositif qui permet de compter
automatiquement le nombre de silhouettes
humaines présentes sur les lieux et donc
d'actualiser les données en temps réel
nous voulons surtout que les gens
puissent bien prévoir leur séjour ici et
qu'il y ait une bonne répartition en
temps et en heure alors comment
peuvent-ils le prévoir il ya un site web
il ya aussi une grande campagne que nous
entamons aujourd'hui si vous allez sur
le site web voilà ce que vous allez y
trouver un onglet planifier votre
cerveau et si vous cliquez dessus vous
trouverez une estimation de l'affluence
pour les jours à venir
ces caméras intelligentes sont équipés
de boîtiers électroniques qui
transmettent les données en temps réel
aux ordinateurs de citymesh l'entreprise
qui a conçu ce dispositif
la société assure qu'aucune image ne
sera conservée ou visionner nous faisons
l'analyse vidéo directement sur
l'appareil
cela veut dire que les images sont
analysés immédiatement et quelques
millisecondes plus tard ces images ne
sont plus disponibles
donc nous allons seulement reconnaître
la forme d'un être humain et déterminer
s'il franchit une ligne virtuelle mais
les images en elle-même ne sont pas
enregistrés ni transmise pour éviter un
déferlement de touristes les communes
flamandes s'appuie également sur les
données des opérateurs téléphoniques des
relevés qui permettent d'observer en
temps réel les déplacements des belges
vers le littoral les informations
commune par commune seront visibles
en temps réel sur le site littoral point
b e ces différentes initiatives sont
appréciés par la population
c'est intéressant pourquoi pas pouvoir
compter la population afin de pouvoir
limiter le nombre de personnes qui
pourraient être présent aussi sur la
commune surtout inquiétant qu'on a
connue c'est peut-être intéressant et
quand même des jours où on se marche
presque sur les pieds donc c'est parfait
pour moi je pense qu'on vient seulement
circonstances moi ça me dérange pas mais
ça gagne ça pourrait ça pourra déranger
si ces précautions basé sur la
technologie ne suffisent pas les
communes flamandes pourront compter sur
une solution plus classique en cas
d'affluence importante sur les plages la
police se chargera d'expliquer la
situation aux touristes trouvent
récalcitrants c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve à 22h pin pour un point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 l'usiné autour
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le monde d'avant il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors pour elle c'était
d'expression vous délirez autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
banda je voulais vraiment montrer que le
monde d'après il serait aussi dynamique
et tonique que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
en pleine crise du couronne le virus
après avoir constaté l'incapacité de
l'union européenne à manifester la
moindre solidarité envers des étapes
l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différente et romont la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
de bien choisir
[Musique]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences est ce selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il y à une impunité assumer il y a
une culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui tablent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer en soit vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck fait que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
what is moi de comprendre ce qui se
passe tout l'enjeu de notre association
c'est construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre lé musée avec trois mois de non
activité où les billetteries sont à
l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera leur démarche sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
de ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché ça
prendra plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde le président un
brésilien janet jackson à rosny la
gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
m
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
deux anciennes ministres de la santé
auditionné cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale marisol touraine et roselyne
bachelot entendus sur la gestion des
stocks de masques en france au lendemain
de l'audition d'agnès buzyn les deux
femmes se refuse à donner des leçons à
leurs successeurs sur la gestion des
crises du coc vide
nous n'avons pas le contrôle total
actuellement l'euro docteur anthony
fauci alerte sur la situation de la
pandémie de covin aux états unis le
directeur de l'institut américain des
maladies infectieuses déplore le tout au
rien pratiqué par nombre d'américains
soit complètement confiné soit sans
aucune distanciation des masques quatre
états californie arizona texas et flo
vide représente aujourd'hui la moitié
des nouveaux cas le controversé plan de
paix américain pour le proche orient au
centre de toutes les attentions au
gouvernement israélien devrait se
prononcer à partir d'aujourd'hui sur la
mise en oeuvre de ce projet il prévoit
notamment l'élection par israël de
plusieurs zones de la cisjordanie
une élection qui pourraient embraser le
proche orient
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez avant de
développer ses titres en russie selon
les premières estimations 73 % des
citoyens ont voté pour le projet de
réforme constitutionnelle
il devrait permettre d'élire poutine
d'effectuer deux mandats supplémentaires
à partir de 2024 pour cette grande
consultation populaire la participation
serait de près de 65% depuis jeudi
dernier les russes étaient invités à se
prononcer par référendum sur le projet
de réforme constitutionnelle voulue par
le président un scrutin étalé sur
plusieurs jours pour éviter une trop
forte affluence en pleine pandémie
france à présent les auditions de la
commission d' enquête sur la crise
ducobu 19 et la question de la gestion
des stocks de masques toujours se
poursuivent et cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale
les ex ministre de la santé marisol
touraine et roselyne bachelot était
entendu cet après midi notre reporter
katia techniques étaient sur place
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé entre 2012 et
2017 a été auditionné durant deux heures
par la commission d' enquête
parlementaire
elle a défendu son bilan selon elle
toujours voulu garder un très haut
niveau de stocks de masques 750 millions
en l'occurrence et ce malgré une
doctrine qui n'était qu'un avis en 2011
puis est devenue une directive en 2013
qui conseillait de sortir de la logique
de stocks massives pour une logique de
flux mais marisol touraine ne le
souhaitait pas elle a donc continuer à
stocker je vous propose de l'écouter
j'ai maintenu l'idée qu'il fallait avoir
des stocks importants
pas seulement pour les masquer je vais
revenir dans un instant et c'est la
raison pour laquelle même si certains
d'entre vous vont dire mais pourquoi n'y
avait il pas un milliard de masques n' y
en avait-il que 754 millions il y avait
7 154 millions de masques à la fin du
mandat
mais lorsque agnès buzyn a pris ses
fonctions et bien très rapidement elle
se serait aperçu que les stocks étaient
périmés ou inexistants l add ons
recommandée mais les stocks n'ont jamais
été reconstitué à la hauteur des
précédents
et puis pourquoi n'at-elle pas su que
ces stocks étaient périmés et bien il ya
un problème de remontée d'informations
marisol touraine a expliqué qu'elle
avait une délégation qui la tenait au
courant très précisément de la quantité
de masques nous avons posé la question à
joachim sun forget qui est un député
présent à cette commission sur la
question des remontées d'informations au
sein des ministères puisque le fait du
masque sa pose à moi je crois un
problème de comment fonctionnent nos
administrations publiques
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans la remontée
d'informations pourquoi est ce que tout
le monde n'est pas collectivement au
courant d'un élément important qui a un
coût financier qui a un coût humain
potentiel sa pelouse plutôt un problème
de qu'est-ce que c'est la logistique
d'êta qu'est-ce que celle que la
communication dans un cabinet
ministériel ou entre peut-être trop de
couches administrative trop d' agences
et ministères et le ministre ça pose
plutôt la question profonde de
l'organisation française des structures
d'état française
et là je pense qu'il ya en effet des
redondances qui font qu'il ya des
messages qui reste on va se clôt au lieu
d'être diffusées largement roselyne
bachelot ancienne ministre de la santé
et des sports entre 2007 et 2010 a
ensuite était auditionné on se souvient
qu'elle avait été critiqué pour ses
commandes jugées excessives de masques
et de vaccins durant l'épidémie de h1n1
eh bien il est resté modeste elle a
expliqué que le contexte à l'époque lui
était bien plus favorable qu'au moment
du corona virus il se trouve qu'elle a
multiplié les salves contre tout et tout
le monde c'est à dire la france un pays
infantiliser les conseils départementaux
l'opinion publique
certains professionnels de santé mais
elle a aussi répondu à une question clé
en main concernant la gestion par un
ministre évidemment on pense à agnès
buzyn est ce qu'être humain ministre
c'est être au courant de tout et bien
selon roselyne bachelot
oui quand on est en charge d'un
ministère ou doit tout connaître
bien sûr et laurent giacomelli porte
parole du rassemblement national à lui
un avis plus tranché sur la question
selon lui l' incompétence et le mensonge
d'état de son responsable de la sec
il sera difficile d'expliquer aux
français notamment ceux qui ont eu des
malades dans leurs familles ou client
était atteint eux mêmes par la maladie
comment et qui est responsable pas de
masque pendant les deux premiers mois de
l'épidémie pas de test disponible de du
cafouillage dans tous les sens il faut
faire blanc le lundi et noir le mardi un
gouvernement qui ment aux français
clairement on est face à une séquence où
l'état a été submergé par la tâche très
sincèrement il y a aussi une part de
légèreté des ministres beaucoup de
rapports et des faits signalant que le
stock des masses s'amenuisait et qu'il
fallait le reconstituer signalant qu'en
cas d'épidémie ou de pandémie même il
fallait pouvoir protéger les français et
qu'il est bien évident de constater que
rien n'a été fait donc je pense qu'on
est face à un double problème
une lourdeur de l'administration c'est
vrai qui a du mal à faire remonter
l'info est un vrai problème
d'incompétence de madame du zinc hui de
monsieur verrons par la suite à de
nouvelles manifestations dès chauffeur
vtc aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines
d'entre eux se sont rassemblés non loin
du ministère de la transition écologique
chargé des transports les représentants
de l'intersyndicale nationale vtc ont pu
s'entretenir avec le secrétaire d'état
avant maciste djebbar ils se sont
ensuite dirigés vers le ministère de
l'économie et des finances leurs
revendications la mise en place d'un
numéro deux us pour les nouveaux
chauffeurs le droit d'accès à la rue de
rivoli ou encore l'obtention d'une
grippe ou qu'ovide actuellement
beaucoup de gens se mettent à faire du
vtc en pensant que c'est l'eldorado mais
il ya beaucoup trop de gens qui rentrent
dans cette profession et donc on arrive
à on a on arrive à des situations où les
gens ne ne vivent pas de leur travail
on demande la prime kovy 19 d'une valeur
de 4000 euros on a vraiment besoin de
cette prime donc 9000 euros en allemagne
4000 euros en belgique 3000 euros en
hollande et et nous 1500 euros de fonds
de solidarité sachant que eux ils ont un
fond de solidarité à hauteur de 1600
euros qui est cumulée à ces primes là
donc nous on est axe fils asphyxié
actuellement économiquement on ne peut
pas s'en sortir monsieur djebbari a
parlé ce matin donc dans une antenne
dans un autre média en disant qu'ils
avaient fait beaucoup de choses avec les
plateformes et qu'ils avaient un prix
minimum
ben il a sciemment menti parce que hume
hubert le tarif kilométrique est bien en
dessous de ce que l'on veut
donc nous n'est pas rentable on ne peut
pas on ne compte déjà plus notre temps
et là maintenant on va bientôt plus
compter notre argent
plus de quarante mille nouveaux cas par
jour les états unis pourraient passer à
100 mille cas journalier si on ne
renverse pas la tendance une prévision
signé anthony fauci
l'un des médecins les plus écoutées
outre atlantique face à la résurgence de
l'épidémie dans le pays plusieurs états
ont décidé de reconfirmer pour éviter le
pire le récit de rania berrada l' alerte
donnée par quatre médecins la tête des
grands organismes de santé américain
suffira-t-elle à inverser la tendance
face à la résurgence de l'épidémie dans
plusieurs états ils ont appelé ce mardi
les américains et en particulier les
jeunes à se couvrir le visage et à
éviter le plus possible les foules
parmi ces hauts responsables antony
fortier qui dirige l'institut des
maladies infectieuses qui dépend du
ministère de la santé
ce mardi face aux sénateurs il a livré
une prédiction sinistre nous
actuellement plus de 40 mille nouveaux
cas par jour je ne serais pas surpris si
nous atteignons cent mille par jour si
on ne reverse pas la tendance
je suis donc très inquiet face à cette
situation sanitaire désastreuse
un sénateur républicain enjoint le
président des états unis a lui-même
porté un masque pour montrer l'exemple
malheureusement cette façon très simple
de sauver des vies est devenue un débat
politique
si vous êtes pour trump et ne portait
pas de masque et si vous êtes contre
trump vous emporté 1-2 c'est pour cela
que je suggère au président de porter un
masque à certaines occasions même si
cela ne lui semble pas nécessaire aucun
commentaire de donald trump qui continue
de tenir la chine pour responsables de
la propagation de l'épidémie aux états
unis quand je regarde la pandémie
répandre son horrible visage à travers
le monde y compris des dégâts qui ont
été faits aux états unis je deviens de
plus en plus en colère contre la chine
les gens peuvent le voir et je peux le
sentir dès son côté joe biden a annoncé
qu'il ne tiendrait pas deux meetings
avant l'élection présidentielle de
novembre
ce dimanche le jour il s'agit de la
campagne la plus étrange de l'histoire
moderne me semble-t-il
je vais suivre les consignes du docteur
pas juste pour moi mais pour le pays et
cela veut dire que je ne vais pas
organisé de motifs face à la résurgence
de l'épidémie
de plus en plus de villes et d'état ont
suspendu leur déconfinement certains en
laissant fermer les bars et les cinémas
d'autres en interdisant l'accès aux
plages ne pas porter de masque à miami
beach
y compris dans la rue coûte désormais 50
$ aux contrevenants dans le sud de la
floride
tous les feux d'artifice du 4 juillet
jour de fête nationale ont été annulés
et pour olivier py ton avocat au barreau
de washington la situation sanitaire et
les réponses qui sont apportées par les
autorités diffèrent largement d'un état
à l'autre
on a une reprise de la pandémie par le
sud et par l'ouest c'est-à-dire d etat
qu des hommes qui jusqu'à présent
n'avaient pas été touchés par le virus
et qui donc aujourd'hui d'une certaine
manière rattrape le reste du pays
en revanche dans le nord-est par exemple
on a une on a une baisse sensible du
nombre de de contamination ce qui fait
que la réaction des gouverneurs qui sont
en première ligne dans chacun des états
pour lutter contre la pandémie pour
prendre les mesures contre la pandémie
est en fait assez disparate c'est à dire
que dans les états du sud très touchés
comme en floride au texas en arizona en
particulier on a recommencé art confiner
les restaurants sont fermés les bars ont
fermé un certain nombre de lieux clos
sont fermés alors que dans d'autres
zones ont continué à des confits des
comme par exemple autour de washington
donc tout dépend comme c'est un pays
fédéral bien entendu tout dépend un
petit peu de la gravité de la pandémie
localement et des décisions qui sont
prises par les gouverneurs après
plusieurs polémiques au sujet du rem
désirent un antiviral contre le coc vide
le laboratoire pharmaceutique américain
gilead vient de fixer le prix du
traitement
il est cher de 1340 dollars un tarif
contesté qui pourrait être accessible
uniquement aux pays riches les
explications en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons fixé le prix un seuil
largement au dessous de sa valeur pour
nous assurer que son accès soient larges
et équitable à un moment où les besoins
mondiaux sont urgents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
urgent le président trump sécurisé
l'obtention de plus de 500 milles dose
du traitement horaire désir pour les
hôpitaux américains jusqu'en septembre
au port jérôme marty médecin généraliste
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre et l'auront alexandre
essayiste et chirurgiens le même désir
est avant tout un traitement qui ne
garantit pas la guérison mais qui
facilite la mairie du collège belrem
désire pas plus que hydroxy cru
le koro qui n'a fait la preuve réelle de
soi l'efficacité on nous parle d'un
traitement qu est un traitement
compassionnel on nous parle d'un
traitement qui diminue le nombre de
jours de maladie de quinze jours en
moyenne à 11 jours mais qui n'a
absolument pas de diminuer le taux de
létalité de la maladie en tout cas de
façon très très faible et pas pas
significatives et là on nous vend des
médicaments dont le prix a été fixé sur
le prix de journée moyen de
d'hospitalisation c'est à dire comme il
ya cinq jours de moins
d'hospitalisations on a fait 5 x x le
prix de journée on a défini de 1330
euros enfin bon c'est tout ça était du
domaine plus financier que véritablement
médicale aujourd'hui très très peu de
gens prescrivent du rem dit pire
donc en réalité et c'est pas un enjeu
extrêmement important parce que cette
molécule peu efficaces et très peu
prescrite
donc ce n'est pas un enjeu majeur de
santé publique on pourrait s'inquiéter
si c'était un médicament extrêmement
efficace comme sont les médicaments dont
la md et vire dans l'hépatite c ou les
médicaments dans le hiv mais là on a un
médicament plus efficace qu'il ne sera
de toute façon pas prescrits dit roach
et planck il n'a pas fait la preuve de
son efficacité leadership brooklyn
effectivement n'est pas cher mais c'est
pas parce qu'un médicament et pas cher
qu'il faut l'utiliser
le prix n'est pas le premier facteur qui
rentrent en ligne de compte le premier
facteur c'est l'efficacité
si on regarde avec le prix ont prescrit
ray de la médecine charlatanesques comme
l'homéopathie à nos patients
des milliers de palestiniens ont
manifesté à gaza contre le plan de paix
américain pour le proche orient ce
projet prévoit l'annexion par israël de
colonies en cisjordanie occupée de la
vallée du jourdain le gouvernement
israélien devrait se prononcer
aujourd'hui sur sa mise en oeuvre depuis
plusieurs semaines aider les gens
palestiniens appellent la communauté
internationale à rejeter ce plan mais
des députés afghans viennent de rejeter
eu l'idée de sanctions contre l'état
hébreu
les explications de remis en dons ou
avec lmh et médias la palestine n'est
pas à vendre et le plan de route ne
passera jamais des dizaines de pancartes
barrées de ses slogans ont vu le jour en
cisjordanie
parmi les événements marquants un grand
rassemblement à jéricho en présence de
nombreux diplomates qui se sont succédé
à la tribune un message fort pour les
palestiniens qui attendent aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus que des mots c'est un plan
qui s'opposent aux droits fondamentaux
des palestiniens
c'est pourquoi nous nous mobilisons vous
voyez ici nous sommes des milliers de
tout le territoire et de toutes les
tendances politiques
c'est encourageant de voir que beaucoup
nous soutiennent aussi l'union
européenne l'onu la russie le japon la
chine
tous ces pays considèrent que nous avons
des droits légitimes au regard du droit
international
nous ne souhaitons pas la destruction
d'israël mais uniquement que l'on
respecte nos droits
jéricho est la capitale de la vallée du
jourdain plaines fertiles qu israël
souhaite notamment annexée sur ses
terres la plupart des agriculteurs
cultivent les dates et le raisin des
produits pour moitié destinée au marché
local et pour l'autre revendu à
l'international ismail ayed promet de
défendre les territoires palestiniens
jusqu au bout
on ne partira pas même si je dois mourir
je ne partirai pas même si je dois
manger de la terre je ne partirai pas on
a laissé notre terre une fois en 48
on ne va pas le refaire personne ne va
partir
même si le couple au on va creuser des
puits avec nos mains ismaila y est comme
beaucoup d'autres gardent espoir il se
bat malgré 53 ans d'occupation de la
cisjordanie par israël depuis les
colonies israéliennes s'étendent des
colonies pourtant illégales selon le
droit international
l'élection conditionnée par les
élections en israël mais aussi aux états
unis selon pour l'asl ailleurs j'en ai
srt internationale il n'aurait pas
intérêt à ne pas demander l'annexion
parce que l'année dernière nous avons
trois élections et sera à chaque
élection avec benjamin netanyahu a
promis une élection il perdrait beaucoup
de sa légimité comme légitimité
politique et le son pouvoir politique
ici ils reculaient maintenant benjamin
netanyahu est incitée par les élections
en novembre aux états unis à agir joe
biden a déjà déclaré qu'il ne supporte
pas qu'il ne soutient pas l'annexion et
le premier ministre israélien a déclaré
à plusieurs reprises israël en le
président américain donald trump son
meilleur ami de l'histoire donc s'il
doit y avoir une annexion à l'heure et
de se faire rapidement
le torchon brûle entre pékin et
washington l annonce de l'entrée en
vigueur de la très controversée loi sur
la sécurité nationale qui vise à étendre
les pouvoirs de la justice chinoise à
hong kong alors que le pays connaît
depuis un an une crise politique sans
précédent
bassem chebbi c'est une nouvelle loi
bien controversé qu'il en a pas fini de
faire parler d'elle et notamment dans
les rangs américains signée jean ping
cette loi adoptée par le comité
permanent du parlement chinois est
accusé par ses détracteurs d'être
liberticide et de constituer un moyen
pour pékin de museler l'opposition
promulguée à hong kong un peu avant
minuit mardi 30 juin par la chef de
l'exécutif qui a ri l'âme
cette nouvelle loi sur la sécurité
nationale étant les pouvoirs de la
justice chinoise en matière d'atteinte
grave à la sécurité nationale menaçant
de prison à vie tous crimes portant
atteinte à cette dernière
cette loi permet de réprimer quatre
types de crimes contre la sécurité
nationale à savoir les activités
subversives la sécession le terrorisme
ou encore la collusion avec des forces
étrangères
il n'aura pas fallu plus pour susciter
l'indignation d'une partie de la
communauté internationale et washington
en tête alors que pas moins de 27 pays
du conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'onu parmi lesquels la france
l'allemagne ou encore le japon ont
condamné cette loi mais face à eux un
groupe de cinquante trois pays ont
apporté leur soutien à pékin en saluant
l'entrée en vigueur du dispositif et en
estimant que cette question ne devait
pas être discutée au conseil des droits
de l'homme
le chef de la diplomatie américaine mike
pompéo à lui menacé l' empire du milieu
de nouvelles sanctions
déplorant je cite un jour triste pour
hong kong et pour tous les amoureux de
la liberté en chine les etats unis ne
resteront pas les bras croisés pendant
que la chine englouti hong kong dans sa
gueule autoritaire des menaces prises
très au sérieux par pékin qui pointe du
doigt une nouvelle tentative
d'intimidation et d'ingérence dans les
affaires internes du pays
nous ne vous avons pas provoquer de quel
droit êtes-vous agressifs avec nous la
loi imposée mardi ne regarde pas les
pays étrangers quant aux pays qui ont
déclaré qu'ils imposeraient de lourdes
sanctions à certains responsables
chinois
je considère qu'il s'agit d'une logique
de bandits de son côté
le chef de l'exécutif hongkongais car
ilham a mis en garde washington contre
toute ingérence
alors que pékin a affirmé que ces actes
sont condamnées à échouer alors hasard
du calendrier ou volonté de marquer les
esprits
la date de sa promulgation coïncide avec
le 23e anniversaire de la rétrocession
de hong kong à la chine par la grande
bretagne
et pourquoi blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales si nombreux
sont les hong kong et à ne pas aimer
c'est toi ils ne peuvent s'y opposer
sans risque pour leur liberté
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui sur le plan
juridique on peut penser qu'il y a une
sérieuse entorse au principe de un pays
deux systèmes ce n'est pas le cas sur le
plan économique puisque bien entendu on
ne change rien reste à savoir quelle
sera l'interprétation des acteurs
économiques alors les grandes banques
comme hsbc ont déjà dit qu'elle a
accepté parfaitement cette nouvelle loi
mais évidemment un certain nombre de
cadres d'entreprise de jeunes également
ne l'acceptent pas et par conséquent la
conteste mais ils sont tout à fait
conscients du risque qu'il courait en
l'affrontant ni gouvernement puisque
évidemment il serait arrêté et mis en
prison les peines sont très lourdes
jusqu'à la prison à vie avec des
possibilité de remise de peine notamment
pour délation c'est à dire pour des non
dénonciation d'autres hongkongais qui
aurait violé la loi alors sacré quand
même un climat un petit peu particulier
face à l'euro nicolás maduro durci le
ton le président vénézuélien exige le
départ de la chef de la délégation de
l'union européenne à caracas et isabelle
briand une réponse aux sanctions
imposées par l'ue à l'encontre de
fonctionnaires vénézuélien dans le même
temps la présidente du conseil national
électoral a annoncé la tenue d'élections
législatives en décembre
parce que tant qu'il sera boycotté par
les partis d'opposition
aujourd'hui comme deux points uniques à
l'ordre du jour nous avons discuté et
élaboré à l'unanimité des règles
spéciales qui régiront les élections
parlementaires de décembre 2020 c'est
important de noter que lors des
prochaines élections parlementaires
correspondant à la période 2021 2026 le
nombre de sièges à élire passera de 167
à 277 ce qui représente une augmentation
de 66% sur les pneumatiques et risque de
s'aggraver car l'union européenne
suivrait la ligne dure des etats-unis
contre le régime mais d'euros c'est ce
qu'affirme farid fernandez consultant et
ancien diplomate
on a une réaction ici du goût du
gouvernement vénézuélien
face à ceux qui l'interprètent comme une
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
du venezuela
et là on peut voir effectivement mettre
en lumière l'échec de cette stratégie
qui vise à face à une démocratie le
venezuela qui qui fonctionne mal du fait
à la fois des tensions internes mais
aussi des pressions externes depuis les
etats-unis principalement on voit
l'union européenne qui depuis des années
avec un train de retard effectivement
constamment derrière les états unis mais
qui suit cette stratégie de pressions
externes contre le venezuela travaille
des sanctions très dures mais qui ne qui
n'atteignent pas leur objectif le
il n'y a pas de progrès dans les
négociations entre les deux camps
venezuela
il n'y a pas d'effet positif de ces
sanctions pour la démocratie
vénézuélienne où les pistes pour que la
société vienne se pacifie on verra
maintenant au sein de l'union européenne
s'il ya des pays
peut-être qu'ils essaient quittance d'un
de modérer la plana la position
européenne
peut-être d'arriver à apaiser les
tensions actuelles honnêtement je n'en
vois pas vraiment le jeu ne crois pas
que ce soit un scénario possible je
pense qu'on va vers une ligne dure
c'est celle qui gagne au sein de l'union
européenne depuis des années avec
effectivement comme je disais tout à
l'heure
cette tentative de de ne pas avoir une
politique autonome une politique qui
favorise la négociation au venezuela
mais une politique qui suit le sel qui
est celle qui est adoptée aux états unis
à washington
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité demain matin 7h du matin par
française excellente fin de soirée à
tous
[Musique]
et
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon et disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
ce coup ci c'est interdit d'interdire
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
je suis sur la voie de gandhi j'essaie
de le copier et même une mauvaise copie
comme noir a de la valeur je ne suis pas
là pour faire de quiconque un disciple
de gandhi je suis là pour trouver le
futur aujourd'hui
et
t'inquiète que nous il n'est pas
seulement utilisée pour filer c'est
aussi l'essence même des idées de gandhi
c'est la philosophie indienne
vous n'avez pas que ce que vous voyez
autour du rire est le reflet de ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de rue c'est
gandhi c'est ce que j'ai compris après
de nombreuses années de travail
[Musique]
lancé ce mouvement de liberté nous a
ouvert cette voie
[Musique]
à pour nous il est une incarnation de
dieu
c'est pourquoi je le prie
je suis la seule personne encore en vie
qui travaillaient avec gandhi et qui
connaissait quand
ce qu'on dit a dit d'abord ils signeront
ensuite ils se moqueront de toi et enfin
elle te rejoindre au
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur des sujets sensibles
je vais partager mon interprétation en
pleine crise du coroner virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam en neuf pays
dont la france ont proposé aux dix neuf
pays de la zone euro de lancer des
cordes la bande pour aider les pays du
sud très durement touché par la pandémie
le principe était simple il s'agissait
de leur permettre de réaliser les
emprunts nécessaires en bénéficiant d'un
taux d'intérêt garanti par l'europe et
non pas celui pratiqué par les prêteurs
au vu de la situation spécifique de
chaque pays concerné devant le refus de
l'allemagne et des pays du nord et de
l'est
le 27 mars cette initiative a été
malheureusement rejetée du coup le 18
mai le président macro qu'un d'un
européen convaincu et la chancelière
angela merkel dont la prudence
européenne est connu mais qui va en
prendre la présidence pour six mois ont
pris l'initiative d'un plan daide à la
reprise économique européenne
un fonds de relance de 500 milliards
d'euros permettra aux vingt-sept
d'emprunter et de rembourser tous
ensemble les dépenses qui est la crise
malheureusement en opposition avec la
solidarité attendu la vidéo réunion du
10 juin des chefs de gouvernement a
montré que rien n'était acquis car la
plupart des pays du nord continue à
s'opposer à une dette commune et freine
toute initiative en dépit des promesses
d'affectation d'une partie des moyens
dans des pays comme la pologne
ce n'est malheureusement pas une
surprise quand on regarde le break site
la part de marché de l'euro le
traitement de la pandémie les réponses à
la crise économique à venir où les
désaccords internes un point certains
l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise
problème est de savoir comment nous en
sommes arrivés là et les solutions
possibles
permettez moi un petit rappel historique
l'union européenne qui comprend
aujourd'hui 28 pays a été créée comme
certains savent bien par le traité de
maastricht signé le 7 février 1992 il
est entré en vigueur le 1er novembre
1993 il a été ratifié du justesse dans
un référendum par 51,05 % des français
cette union européenne est issu de la
communauté économique européenne qu'on
appelait le marché commun fondé en 1957
par le traité de rome entre six pays
l'allemagne l'italie la france les pays
bas la belgique et le luxembourg pour
réaliser une unité économique et
politique et garantir une paix durable
au départ l'entente entre le chancelier
konrad adenauer et le général de gaulle
a permis de faire progresser sa mise en
oeuvre
en dépit de multiples difficultés s'ils
entrées successives de l'espagne puis de
l'italie n'ont posé aucun problème
l'arrivée de la grande bretagne à casser
la mécanique d'unités progressive car
son objectif exclusif était la création
d'une zone de libre échange économique
et il faut bien le dire très
individualiste elle a mené un combat
permanent
jusqu'au break site le traité de
maastricht signé par le président
mitterrand et le chancelier helmut kohl
avec 13 autres pays a mis en place une
citoyenneté européenne et à consacrer
des délégations de compétence à l'union
en s'appuyant sur trois piliers les
communautés européennes c'est à dire la
communauté économique du charbon et de
l'acier et or at home la politique
étrangère et de sécurité commune qu'on
appelle la pes c'est et la coopération
dans les domaines de la justice et des
affaires intérieures dont le point le
plus connu et schengen
ces transferts de souveraineté
s'accompagner de la volonté de mettre en
place une défense commune à laquelle le
temps c'est évidemment opposé à travers
le lancement de l'union économique et
monétaire
r elle a aussi jeté les bases de l'euro
qui sera lancée vous en souvenez entre
1999 et 2002 et regroupe à ce jour 19
états membres qui en ont fait leur
monnaie nationale
ce choix est extrêmement important car
en réalité il concrétise la séparation
de l'union en deux parties ceux qui ont
une monnaie commune et ceux qui restent
sur les bases d'une entente
essentiellement commerciale l'arrivée
des 10 pays anciennement membre du bloc
soviétique a compliqué la situation déjà
très difficile car leurs objectifs sont
différents ils veulent avant tout et
c'est compréhensible être protégés
contre toute agression venues du nord
en s'appuyant sur le temps et profiter
de l'union européenne pour bénéficier
des aides économiques et de marché pour
l'emploi et la commercialisation de
leurs produits
et ceci est apparu très clairement avec
la création du groupe devise garde qui
réunit la hongrie la pologne la tchéquie
et la slovaquie dont les politiques et
objectifs sont fréquemment en opposition
avec les pays fondateurs du sud de
l'union
profitant de sa puissance retrouvée par
la réunification et la remise à plat de
ses fondamentaux par l'ancien chancelier
gerhard schröder
angela merkel a utilisé son efficacité
politique indéniable et les capacités
industrielles de l'allemagne pour
devenir le pays de référence pour les
pays du nord et les pays de l'est
dans le même temps les pays du sud ont
essayé sans succès de monter l'union
pour la méditerranée afin de
contrebalancer la puissance économique
des pays du nord et de l'est de l'union
faut y ajouter que la grèce la crise de
la grèce rentrer dans l'union européenne
grâce à des comptes publics modifier à
l'aide d'une grande banque américaine a
pénalisé l'ensemble de la zone euro mais
aussi ses crises a convaincu les pays du
nord et de l'est que ceux du sud qu'ils
appellent péjorativement le club med ne
sont pas des partenaires sérieux la
crise du bric site a entrouvert la porte
de sortie du système en montrant que
ceux ci pouvaient se faire avec un
niveau de risque acceptable pour le pays
sortant comme le montre le bilan
provisoire des négociations en cours
l'italie qui a pris de plein fouet la
crise du coronavirus et n'a eu il faut
le rappeler
aucune aide européenne alors qu'elle en
a obtenu d'autres pays
après avoir été attaqué pour ses
résultats économiques y compris par les
français est très remonté contre
bruxelles et les autres états membres
c'est ainsi qu'un sondage a montré des
italiens considèrent la chine et la
russie
comme l'heure le meilleur ami et
s'oppose aux pays européens qui les ont
laissés tomber
du coup devant la menace la présidente
de l'union ursula van leyen a présenté
ses excuses et la proposition de
création du fonds de relance par la
chancelière allemande participe de cette
volonté de calmer les esprits
paradoxalement il faut le dire ce sont
les chinois qui ont le moins intérêt à
la sortie de l'italie
car ils en ont fait leur terminus dans
l'europe du sud de la route de la soie
et ont besoin d'y bénéficier des
conditions européennes
exactement comme les gars femmes
américains ont utilisé l'irlande il ya
quelques années
la crise de l'euro est également un
problème selon la bce dont la politique
est mise en cause par la cour
constitutionnelle allemande à karlsruhe
la part de marché de l'euro sur le
marché des capitaux était de 24 % avant
la crise de 2008 ce qui en faisait un
acteur majeur entre le dollar américain
et le one chinois elle était en début
2000 22-19 -5% la montée en puissance de
la chine dans le commerce mondial a
évidemment réduit le poids de l'euro
mais comme le fait remarquer la
chroniqueuse elle la connaît ça il faut
y ajouter la fragmentation de la zone
euro et son incapacité à parler d'une
seule voix ce qui la rend beaucoup moins
attractive avec la crise actuelle
à quoi s'ajouteront la promotion de la
livre anglaise et la city de l'ombre à
la suite du bric site
nul doute que sa part de marché va
encore baisser par ailleurs la rigidité
allemande sur la stabilité de la monnaie
qu'elle a imposés à maastricht lui a
permis de devenir la première puissance
européenne
elle s'oppose aux économies des pays du
sud qui était habitué à gérer par un
processus d'inflation et de dévaluation
que l'on retrouve depuis 20 ans dans les
difficultés à s'inscrire dans les règles
budgétaires de maastricht en raison de
la crise actuelle
vous noterez que l'allemagne vient de
relâcher sa rigueur car sa relance de
l'économie qui utilisent pour une bonne
partie ses réserves financières l'amène
à sortir de ses propres règles mais dans
un an elle sera revenue dans ses
objectifs
alors qu'il va nous falloir un minimum
de trois à quatre ans pour y parvenir
étant obligé de tout emprunté d'où
l'importance des taux pratiqués dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
sur le plan défense l'union est tiraillé
entre l'otan sous commandement américain
qui a tendance à sortir de ces règles
d'emploi initiale et la défense
européenne qui permet d'assurer sa
souveraineté face aux deux blocs
en réalité la plupart des états membres
ne souhaitent pas investir dans un
budget militaire
ils suivent l'exemple des deux grands
perdants de la deuxième guerre mondiale
le japon et l'allemagne qui en ont fait
la démonstration économiques en
investissant pendant 40 ans dans leur
industrie
les 3 % annuels que nous consacrions à
la défense ailleurs vrai seuls les
français les anglais ont maintenu un
effort réel de défense depuis la guerre
car ceux ci leur père